Ừ
rồi ok thế man tôi không ạ
à à chào các bạn Hôm nay là một buổi à
cuối tuần thứ 7
bố mẹ tôi cũng vừa học xong mà chịu khó
là không à bụng học này ra là hôm nay
học cả ngày khá mệt rồi Hôm nay thực ra
tôi chẳng hiểu cái môn học rồi học cái
gì nó điện toán đám mây chứ nhưng mà nó
cái gì cứ gửi link tài liệu tự đọc thôi
à
khi gà hấp Liên Hồng Nó là cái tôi đã đã
từng hi vọng và cũng đã được nói trước
đó là à
khoa học liên thông thì cần Như à Cũng
chẳng có học được cái nước gì cả Mình
đưa cái hội học để lấy cái bằng thôi
trường nào thế nên là không quan trọng
về chưa Quan trọng là cái bàn ở chỗ nào
nó giá trị hơn nó có cái mác nào bởi vì
hồi trước tôi nhớ là cái bằng bằng
phải trước à nó thêm chữ tại chức hay
cái gì đói
nó không đi thêm có nếu mà học nên không
ở Bách Khoa Hà Nội thì nó cầm nó có thêm
về chữ Tại trước cái gì đó nghĩa là phải
bằng chính quy thành ra là kiểu và tôi
tôi cũng không ham hố vào cái Liên hậu
các trường kiểu cao giúp nhớ đặt ở đây
họ đã học Bách Khoa Đồ gì à
vì nó có thêm để chữ ở trong này băng mà
là cả cũng không học hỏi được cái gì cả
anh cũng xác định là học lên hồng hả
kiểu con như để lấy cái bằng trong vài
cái kiến thức mà nên trường đạt được
hiệu thế
ờ ờ ờ
thì nhọn giống như cái câu mà ngày này
còn nên học à nên cần có cái bằng cấp
này không ờ
ít nhất là
ờ ờ em hãy nói cho các bạn cứ xác định
tại sao lại cần phải học là chị đã đúng
không
Tại sao cần phải học đại học có bằng cử
nhân và thạc sĩ không ạ Các bạn mục đích
hướng đến làm cái nghề gì
Còn nếu mà bạn nói nhanh này chung thì
đa số đa số thì sẽ không cần bằng cấp
chỉ khi mà các bạn làm cho nhà nước hoặc
là về sau đi dạy ở đại học chính quy
giống như vì sao mình có thể mình mình
mình này đang hướng đến về sau biết đâu
được phía sau mình có thể làm giảng viên
ở trường đại học thì đúng là nên cần có
bằng cấp hoặc có đi đâu thầu gì đó Nói
chung nhà mình nghĩ à
có nhiều người cũng thấy khuyên với mình
ngay cả thầy trước của mình cũng thường
lời khuyên đó là là có bằng cấp thì kể
ra thì
cái cái về về đòi hỏi với mức độ lương
ấy so với người không có bằng cấp ấy
đúng là nó hơn một tí nhưng mà Đấy Tùy
công ty và công ty về sau thời gian mà
quan tâm thì cái chứng chỉ của ông nhiều
hơn là sử ông có chứng chỉ về tiếng Anh
nào ạ sẽ có lợi thế hơn anh Văn Văn cái
ờ ờ
em còn nói chung thì
I Guess thì tôi lại không thích không
thích ngoài việc là ngoài việc như tôi
bảo thì cái này này nó không quan trọng
vì Bằng cấp thì tôi lại không thích về
Bởi vì số đông số đông những người có
bằng cấp theo ngày này thì lại không
giỏi trong ngành này lắm
Ừ nếu mà ông theo hướng về làm công nghệ
tại sao như thế bởi vì nếu mà giả sử với
ông học học xong đại học ông ngoại hỏi
liên thông lên thạc sĩ đúng ạ thì ông ấy
Ông chỉ cắm đầu không học học khá nhiều
Lê Lý thuyết nên hạnh ra là ở cái kỹ
năng của ông cũng như là ở kinh nghiệm
thực tế của ông rất là ít ra hạn hẹp nên
là ông đi làm đặc biệt cái ngành này là
ngành mà kiểu phải va chạm nhiều phải
phải trải nghiệm thực tế ông ấy hiểu
được lý thuyết là không đủ thì không làm
được ngày này đó kết hợp với việc là ờ
khi kết hợp với việc là tôi thấy rất
nhiều âm thạc sĩ kẹo dạng là nói lý
thuyết mà nói máy móc khóa thành ra là
Kiều nó không áp dụng được đâu đâu cả
nên là thậm chí ở Tôi thấy việc mà giảng
viên Đây là cần có bằng thạc sĩ của ngày
này
Ừ thì là chưa đủ hoặc là say thật nghĩa
sai bởi vì a
các giáo viên dạy ở đại học bây giờ đại
học hỏi noi nhá đều kiểu dạng là làm
sinh viên nhiều mông lung như chùa đã
tôi dùng từ như thế khi mà dạy học về
ngành công nghiệp tin này không biết
ngành khác thế nào là ngày không về
thông tin này tôi thấy là tại sao các
trường nghề với ở lại lại được sinh ra
đổ ngoạn về ngày công nghệ thông tin Chỉ
đơn giản bởi vì cái trường đại học chính
quy nó dậy khiến nó dạy cậu không không
đủ đáp ứng để cho kiểu phải sinh ra các
trường dạy nghề hiện nay này và các
trường nghề đấy lại tỷ lệ đi làm cao hơn
cũng như làm được việc hơn đấy con đương
nhiên là đương nhiên tôi không phủ nhận
việc là học đại học chính quy y thì các
bạn sẽ dành được về cái nền cũng như là
tư duy nhưng mà nhà
cái tỷ lệ để nó thoát ra tôi thấy tỷ lệ
thấp
cho ví dụ điển hình nha Bây giờ tôi đang
ví dụ điện một cái thực tế đi là tôi
đang đang định hả đầu con về bên A FPT
Software để mà nó lại FPT k-academy rất
là thế và để mai dậy và cũng nhiều trên
link cho các bạn
để mà vào được công ty nghĩa các bạn đấy
sẽ là kiểu có cái nền có sẵn để nền Và
thậm chí ở chưa có không biết được nhưng
mà thường mà sẽ còn dẫn đến nền rồi còn
nhiều fan kiểu thế thì cần phải có kinh
nghiệm thực tế nữa thôi nó ngon thì tôi
sẽ người đào tạo bế mạc đấy và những bạn
đấy thường những kẻ bạn mà học từ đại
học chính quy ra bạn này không có từ
kinh nghiệm thực tế nào hãy cầm như thế
thì tôi sẽ về sau tôi sẽ người đào tạo
mấy bạn đấy và tôi khẳng định là
à à
anh khẳng định là kiểu dạng là đại học
Bách Khoa vào tỷ lệ vào cao lắm Tôi có
nghe mà mày cái trường top đầu và cao
xong rồi cùng ra cũng vớt vát được ít
lắm nè bây giờ không tuyển theo trường
đại học nữa bữa nay với đây rồi Không
tiền cho trường đại học nữa mà kiểu
không quan tâm thì cái bằng cấp sự các
bạn nữa về đăng tuyển được thoải mái hơn
rồi hồi trước thì chị Chị Tuyền Những
thời đại học top đầu đó nhá ngờ bây giờ
thấy à Nói thẳng lúc đầu giờ nó cũng hơi
bị gặp Nham và cũng như à
Cậu dạng Mấy bạn ấy cứ kiểu bị lung lay
hơn cả những người bạn học không phải
học đại học tốt đâu tưởng như thế
lên trình Đúng không ngày ngày thời ra ở
cũng đúng đúng
anh như tôi đã bảo thì đó là ngày này
thì đó không cần nói đó họ rất là thông
minh để phải theo ngày này gà bạn mà
kiểu dạng mà cái
cái gọi là ở
thì các bạn cầu dạng là thấy ưu và nhược
của ngày này mà thấy mình phù hợp với nó
thì mình theo dõi không phải mỗi ngành
này rất kinh Anh Khác Họ sẽ thế Nói
chung là cái yếu tố cần ở trong máy
nhanh này tôi thấy nó không phải là
thông minh nói chung là chỉ cần không có
tư duy khác người đến nỗi mà kiểu mình
làm những cái phần mềm không giống ai
không phải không giống ai mà không ai
dùng được thì thế là hơi sai cái kiểu
như thế còn một khi mà ông đã có kiểu tư
duy của một người bình thường rồi cho
ông
ông kiểu dạng chăm chỉ chịu khó thì ngày
nào đâu đấy à
gì Cái này chắc là tùy từng công ty Bây
giờ thì nha thường là IELTS thì sẽ là để
mà đi du học cái gì nó còn tôi ấy cả
được rồi
chỉ cách học cái gì cơ cơ cấu trúc dữ
liệu và giải thuật
Tôi nói là tôi học cái mông thì ba lần
tội chẳng nhớ đâu rồi không biết khuyên
nữa Không như thế nào nhưng đại khái thì
cái đấy Tôi từng nói qua nó là chỉ là
một cái nền cái bước đệm để mà Cửa Ông
biết cách về về về
cậu dạng Đoàn thiết kế cơ sở di động
nhưng mà đấy nó lại không áp dụng để lắm
về sau ông sẽ phải tín hiệu kiểu thực tế
phải cần làm theo những gì nữa Chứ thực
ra không có một khái niệm là chuẩn hoàn
toàn cả à
yêu cầu tối thiểu cần bằng đại học cao
cao đẳng Vân Vân đúng thực ra bởi các
trưởng các trang web bây giờ vẫn còn để
điều đấy nhưng mà có một sự thật thì
giống như ngay tôi điển hình ạ tôi đi
thực tập ngay từ năm thứ hai người còn
mà tôi vậy Tôi đang học cao đẳng hãy cần
như thế thì nó nó không phải là kiểu Các
bạn thấy yêu cầu bằng cấp gì ở đây cả
cũng như bây giờ tôi sắp được tuyển về
để làm thành viên mà nói người ta chẳng
hỏi tôi là học trường gì có bằng gì đấy
thì khi mà ông Khi mà ông có đủ kinh
nghiệm thực tế rồi Vân ông chứng minh
được năng lực của ông cũng như đam mê
của ông thì cái bằng cấp mà không quan
trọng đương nhiên Đông nhiên là khi mà
ông nộp Cái cv cho mấy người kia mà ông
không ghi Bằng cấp thì nó cũng hơi một
điểm trừ nhưng mà tôi từng dậy mấy ông
ấy biết cái CV rồi đó là mấy ông phải có
những cái Ừ để cho người ta có cái mà
đọc nó ngoại đó là cái kinh nghiệm thực
tế của ông Tuy không có thì phải ghi âm
đã từng làm đấy Giống Như Tôi bảo là mới
nhất hai cái đồng hai cái đồ án thì thì
xong rồi ông sẽ được kê là ông xong cái
đùa nữa mà làm những cái gì thì nó sẽ ổn
Còn nếu mà ông không có gì để khoe thì
đúng là họ không có gì cả để nhìn vào để
mà tin tưởng với ông cả đúng ạ
Đúng rồi bạn kia nói cho nó lấy kinh
nghiệm thực tế đều lên cái chưa tôi rồi
Tôi có ghi chị trong CV tôi tôi không
ghi Bằng cấp thì luôn không có chứng chỉ
có bằng cấp gì cả ngầu mày ông xem lại
cái tivi Cần anh nhớ tôi đang tớ vẫn
được truyền nó không quan trọng với cái
điều đấy trong cái ngày này á
ờ ờ
cho mấy công ty gần đây chị Tuyển
fullstack thôi hả anh Thực ra là
đúng là công ty hiện tại của tôi cũng
mang tiền xu sách và đúng là một vài
công ty hiện tại Việt Nam thế nhưng mà
đấy là những công ty mà thiếu nhân lực
như là phải kiêm cả hai con nếu mà công
ty nào mà cậu nói chung nhà nó đủ lớn
rồi thì ra là mỗi người chỉ là một phần
thôi không không kiêng được cả hai cùng
một lúc như thế được đâu
trường trong ngành này đúng không Nếu mà
trong ngày này thì ra thì ông sẽ kiểu
dạng là ông nên chuẩn bị tâm lý trước
câu hỏi kĩ năng người cả những nhớ ông
vẫn phải vẫn phải cao nên đi tập trước
khi ra trường luôn cái hợp việc và không
nên có một cái pack mà tôi từng báo đấy
để làm hạn một cái một cái gì đó của
riêng minh để mà ngoài việc là thể hiện
mình đam mê cũng như là mình tự tìm tòi
một cái gì đó đấy Nói chung không phải
kiểu dạng là trên lớp làm đầy đủ bài tập
kiểu có bằng loại giỏi thì thì ra trường
sẽ có công việc không phải như thế mà
ông sẽ kiểu cần thêm vài cái nữa Thậm
chí tôi bảo đấy có ông đi Xù làm lao
động chân tay kiểu kiểu drap hãy vân vân
đồ kia đem gì để mà ông vừa kiếm thêm
một tí cũng nhờ thêm cả thiện được kỹ
năng là cả Thiện kết hợp việc ở ông xem
thực sự là ngành khác có phù hợp mình
hay không để mình sẽ khá chắc chắn hơn
vì cái ngành mình em có phù hợp với mình
hay không Đúng không ngày sử mấy ông xã
Ông thử mọi ngành mà ngày nào cũng chán
có mỗi ngày Hiện tại ông thấy phù hợp
nhất thì ông sẽ không còn đắn đo gì cả
đúng rồi ông sẽ kiểu tự tin hơn trên cái
con đường mình chọn chứ về sau không còn
đắn đo không có kiểu không có nghĩ đường
lui vân vân những người mà đắn đo như
thế thì không tiền không tìm nhanh ở
không tiến xa rồi
ờ ờ
a disaster thì cần ôn tập những cái gì
thường là thực ra là đã từng có người
trả lời câu này hộ tôi trong nhóm chat
rồi Nó là kiểu ông sẽ nói cho ông cầm là
em xin ứng tuyển vào đâu nữa nếu là bác
em là đương nhau sẽ còn biết ở Nếu mà
thuật toán như tốt đi dài 3 tuần xong
rồi à Ở
nói chung và về đã ra bay cơ sở Lý hậu
đấy lại khoái như thế để những cái cấp 3
Ừ nhưng mà fast ở thời gian là nó không
hẳn là đòi hỏi mấy cái sắc hay lắm Ờ
chắc chắn là nó họ cũng sẽ hỏi qua với
những cái dự án ông đã từng là của ông
sẽ nên bà thường người ta sẽ hỏi những
câu rất là hay giống như bao cậu ở trong
cái dự án đấy em đã học hỏi được những
cái gì cái gì là khó khăn nhất đối với
em à và em giải quyết nói như thế nào ở
trong cái vừa ăn đấy dự án bên cái khó
nhất là gì và Vân Đấy ông cứ nghĩ trước
những câu như thế không trả lời trước
thì ông sẽ cảm thấy tự tin hơn
picture và một công ty họ cho off level
Junior thì làm của quá sức không ạ
Ông ấy tự xem đánh giá xem có sức 20
chức cái việc là bây giờ là để mà xem
người vừa một công ty đây một cái công
việc hiện tại của nào phù hợp với ông
không ngày này nói chung
ngày này hoặc cả thận chứ ở ngành khác
nhé lại khá rồi ông ông ngoài việc là
ông Hướng đi làm cái này sẽ hơi khó vì
nhiều người bảo hưng đam mê vì tiền thì
không có hạn ở hướng Huy làm tao làm
ngày nào được nhưng đại phá gì ông còn
có những cái thích muốn làm hay không
này việc ông còn học họ được thêm cái gì
không Hiện tại ông nào faster ông phải
xác định tư tưởng của Ông đó là ông Hiện
tại ông đang mục tiêu là gì những mục
tiêu đang cấy tiền Bây giờ thì có khi
làm faster chưa phải lúc của ông cái
tiền đã đưa trong ngày này Đấy phía fan
junyo nắm được khái niệm có gì đấy ông
chỉ có kiến thức thôi mà Một khi yêu ông
đã xác định ở ông đến thì cái kiến thức
thì ông sẽ Em nghĩ rằng công việc hiện
tại của ông cũng như người mà giúp hỗ
trợ ông Ngô Văn nó có đang đang kiểu
Củng cố thêm kiến thức Củng cố thêm kinh
nghiệm vân vân trông không Nếu mẫu làm
đi làm lại đúng mỗi việc thậm chí ông đi
pha trà ạ để dùng từ thú vị như hết cửa
dạng công ty thuê ông thuê ông ta làm
cái chân vặt sai Chẳng hạn khi thì hoàn
toàn không phù hợp cái cái cái mong ước
nguyện vọng của ông đúng không thiếu
nghỉ thôi
cho con cái việc về người ta làm giao
trong nhiều việc quá thì ông ông xem là
kiểu nó sẽ trong và bao lâu kết hợp việc
tô Hồi trước là công ty còn chả tôi
lương khá bèo bọt bằng ạ Vẫn chấp nhận
được đấy miễn là tôi vẫn còn đang học
hỏi thêm được bởi vì coi như là mình
đang đi học thôi đúng không Mình cũng
được không Không phải trả tiền học mình
kiểu gần đi là mình được người ta trợ
cấp Mình học ở đấy ạ Không sao cả nó dù
tôi bảo rồi làm một tháng lương một
triệu để nó full ha mà no nhé
này thì Nhưng mà phải đến cái giai đoạn
nào đó mà ông cảm thấy ông học đủ rồi
cái hợp này ra vẫn bóc lột âm và cảm
thấy không một tương lai được tương lai
sao phải 1225 nữa rồi nóng rồi trả lương
cho mình xứng đáng thì thì lúc đấy có
thể nhảy việc ngày ngày thời gian nghỉ
việc rất nhiều nhưng mà không phải cân
nhắc đến nhất mà tôi từng nói là ông
không phải đụng với ông nên nghỉ việc
bởi vì nó rẽ vào danh sách đen của các
nhà Tuyển dụng nói ông sẽ phải khi mà
ông phải công việc cũng nhờ ông phải sắp
xếp công việc hợp lý đã bất kỳ ngày nào
thế thôi văn hóa nghỉ việc để thứ hai đó
là
ông nghỉ việc và phải vì do gì Nói chung
Vân Vân không phải vì chán ấy ông nhỉ Em
à Chán nhỉ Không tôi không biết ông theo
này ngày không về ngay quanh quẩn đi Con
còn lại được khi nó Chị cứ thế ông ông
đam mê được cái trán của nó thì ông ấy
heo ngày nay ờ
sắp hết năm nhất Mà lập trình si ở phía
thon của tôi còn mơ hồ
mặc tôi khá hay tìm tòi về lập trình
cái thứ nhất là
Em đừng có nói về lý thuyết mà ông lên
thực hành nhiều xong rồi về sau ông thầy
cùng cô lý thuyết sau Cái quan trọng là
khi mà ông đang theo ngày này không phải
bắt được cái mặt thì ông đam mê này đã
còn nếu vòng đã đam mê rồi thì ông không
nên so sánh mình với bất kỳ ai Kiều tặng
nhà thằng bạn tôi học cái cái ngôn ngữ
hay Hán nó hiểu nó làm được món like rồi
tôi nửa năm rồi vẫn chưa được cái gì cả
Không không nên so sánh kiểu thế mà ông
Chỉ ông sẵn sàng người chính ông ấy Ông
thông Khoái nhất là cậu ông làm ông học
và ông thực hành nhiều số 12 tháng sau
ông có cảm thấy là mình tiến bộ hơn cho
dù kể một tí nữa nhé so với mình hay
hàng trước 20 ngày cứ thế cứ thế mình
tiến chậm không sao cả bởi vì đấy à cái
thằng kia có nên người ta là nhãn mình
thằng bình thiên bình thường thôi ngọn
không sao cả xe tải nếu mà ông cảm thấy
là ngày này phù hợp với ông này phù hợp
nhất với ông không muốn chọn ngành khác
thì ông đi chậm cũng được có sao đâu
không sao còn hơn và kiểu ông Cư ngồi So
sánh ông ấy nghĩ như thế thì ông Xanh
ngày nào nó cũng thế thôi ông sang ngành
Marketing tự nhiên thấy thằng kia sale
bán hàng tốt thế kiểu một ngày nhìn đơn
rồi ông bán một ngày chưa được đơn nào
mới được 12 đơn nhưng ạ yêu còn nản hơn
lúc đấy thì ông Định nhảy nghe ông chẳng
nhảy kìa à
ờ ờ Nhà không có điều kiện thì nên theo
trường quân đội 2 trường ngoài ạ
Tôi không biết về cả hai thường này nó
rồi không biết khuyên ông như nào Nhưng
mà Nhà không có điều kiện thì đại khái
thì đương nhiên à cái câu đấy nó nói khá
nhiều rồi đúng không Nó Chị ở chúng ta
cần cân nhắc chọn thường thì
ông cứ phải nhắn cho ông vào mới cài
group Fanpage của không thường rồi của
mấy cái trường nên qua mấy ông thử hỏi
thử inbox mấy bạn amin JJ đó Nói
chung với bạn mà tôi nói sinh viên là
kiện sinh viên đấy hỏi xem khi bé học
phí các thứ thứ tại yêu à
trong Cũng thú vị vết lâu lắm rồi tôi
không xem thuê có giảm không cho
à à
Em đang học đang học lớp thuật toán nâng
cao thì phát hiện nhà lớp có
an
toàn mấy âm có bằng cao mình 15 thứ tư
có gì ở áp lực mấy ông kia áp lực cho
sao lực cái ông suy nghĩ Đánh rất nhiều
lúc là kiểu mấy ông gặp một cái tình
huống gì đói mấy ông người đi qua này
tôi suy nghĩ là quan vãi ví dụ để ông
kia nó nhá 9 Ông Nam Ông học à thạc sĩ
nữa đấy thạc sĩ rồi nó hết tê ca sĩ này
nó như cha à
Thì mấy ông kia áp lực cái chứ Nó là
người ông ấy học cao rồi mà Mấy ông ấy
sai cái gì đó có nhiều bị bêu bị trêu
ngay đúng không Ông Năm từ ông đầy ông
xài thoải mái Chẳng sao có gì mà được
hạ tầng không
Tôi hướng đến là lập trình web và lập
trình cụ thể là bác em nè Tôi không
chuyên về mấy cái về hệ thống hạ tầng gì
cả Tôi không có tâm điện thoại lắm không
biết ông ấy hướng đến theo bên nào
vậy là lưu lại trong chiếc xe đấy nó
không truyền lên hay nhiều chị chắc chắn
chỉ Lê ở trong suốt gì nữa mà nó không
để ở trong kia không
Nó giống cho xin flash nhỉ Thế anh nghĩ
Để ơi nhưng mà thử cái mình mở label lên
là mình dễ hiểu rõ cơ mà
lên Bây giờ ông không tin tưởng mấy ông
thì ai tin ông nữa đúng không Tôi tôi
nói rồi Cái cái kiểu cái châm ngôn biến
đa cấp là gì ông phải tin là sản phẩm
tốt thì ông ấy đi Khuyên người khác được
sản phẩm tốt chính không cũng không tin
được sản phẩm tốt 5 sao lừa dối người
khác mà sản phẩm mới tốt Nói chung là
thứ nhất có thể không
sản phẩm tệ hại thì ông phải lừa được
bản thân ông là sản phẩm tốt hãy kêu
kiểu nó là như thế ông không tin nữa thì
hay tin được không được đúng không ạ
Em 30 tuổi có kịp học cốt không
Anh ở mình từng dậy người lớn tuổi nhất
là gần 40 Mình ở thế 38 39 gì đấy
nhưng mà bây giờ lên thì 40
và người đấy rùa rất là chậm dùng từ rất
là chậm bởi vì đó họ cũng đều lần gọi là
mới tiếp xúc với máy tính thôi nhưng họ
có cái ý chí nói cho mọi thứ
ra người ta phải là lo lắm Mình khẳng
định là những người mà trên 30 rồi học
kiểu đã gọi hóa
cũng có tuổi không ạ trong cái khi mà đi
làm chắc chắn nó đi làm nhiều rồi và họ
phải rất cân nhắc trước khi chọn quyết
định đặc biệt theo ngành này về ngày này
rõ ràng mà thường ở trẻ chọn hơn người
có tuổi tầm tuổi đấy
nhưng mà khi họ chọn Họ đàn lo lắm rồi
và họ Thược không có kiểu à
chứ không phải chắc chắn ở ông sẽ nghĩ
là ông chọn nó không được không Không
Lùi thì mới được về chắc chắn à Tôi từng
quen rất nhiều người mà
Vì sao ngày này và vì sao vẫn giỏi
chỉ có vài anh còn bây giờ bắt đầu viết
à Block hư thứ gần đây nhất tôi có đọc
anh đấy là dân kinh tế anh để còn làm
kinh tế rất là giỏi được gần cơ tự nhiên
là nhiều người sẽ bảo ông ấy giỏi ông
trời xanh ngày nào được nhưng mà không
không phải đó làm kinh tế rất giỏi ông
không biết một tí gì về công em tin sau
đó là khi uống biết được cái hay không
em vịt ông người bắt đầu học từ đầu của
công nghệ thông tin tức làm thì ở người
ta bắt đầu cũng có số không như mình
thôi
Quan trọng thứ nhất là họ có ý gì hơn
cái đấy Các ngắn hay họ cũng có thể của
cái tư duy hơn nhưng mà
có ai chẳng có bắt đầu như nhau đúng
không
quan trọng thời điểm quan trọng là chúng
ta ý chí hay hơn ai này tư duy với có tư
duy tốt thì chắc chắn là hơn người tư
duy không tốt lắm ngoạn thì họ sẽ tìm
nhanh hơn thôi nhưng họ vẫn tiến quan
trọng là mình có tiếng thấy không ạ
ờ ờ
nên là mình nghĩ là ở các bạn chim hỏi
có này Thực ra các bạn đang khá lưỡng lự
rồi nhưng mà các bạn mà
nhà mình có phải khuyên được là ai cũng
nên cho ngày này mẹ từng nó rồi nhà ngày
Thực ra thì ai cũng nên biết về lập
trình để mà biết về công nghệ cũng như
là
nó làm một cái con đường một cái lựa
chọn để các bạn thể chọn nhưng mà không
phải là ai cũng đam mê được cái ngày này
và theo ngày này không thể ai cũng được
nhìn đâu romeno ra lương mì đô nhiều
người thường anh nói ví von thế nhằm mục
khi ông lên được lương Một mùa khi ông
chỉ cần chạm để lương nghìn đô đấy ông
nên 2000 23 người đội rất là dễ hãy gửi
hết
Có những người làm trong ngành này 785
như tôi ông nói vẫn chỉ mức ở gần như
chưa đến nỗi Sino Lương Nguyễn chỉ 78
triệu có màu rất nhiều nhé 27 tháng 5
nhé nhưng mà có những người hai năm thì
lên xin em đấy thì
vì tôi nghĩa là mẹ ông
các bạn
anh 30 cháu lớn hơn mình rồi thì
anh cứ thủ Xem chính học chính cái khóa
cơ bản của em khá nhanh chỉ có một máy
khám thì anh xem ngày này phù hợp với
không mà có thể tự quyết định được tiếp
thôi em sẽ không thể khuyên tất cả mọi
người theo cùng Hoàng này được nghe nó
như đã cấp đấy nó không đúng đâu à
[âm nhạc]
không so sánh gì không biết được mình đã
học thêm cái gì ngon thì ông phải có
phải đặt một cột mốc màu đó ông khi ông
đạt được cột mốc đấy ông sẽ đặt một cái
đít nữa lớn Sau đó ông đọc trong những
cái cột mốc nhỏ ông đạt được cột mốc nhỏ
đấy ông sẽ biết ông tiến bộ hơn thôi ông
ạ
anh em phải and Training mà hiện tại tại
sao em cảm thấy mông lung kiểu gì ấy
có kinh nghiệm cốt của em mà nhiều tư
duy cũng tốt
Ừ ông có khoai điểm với tôi đúng không ạ
ờ ờ các bạn thực ra là các bạn không nên
lo lắng các bạn đương nhiên là cái nói
cái câu ở kiểu các bạn đừng buồn nữa hay
các bạn đừng lo nữa thì không phải đùng
gan không tao sẽ không lo nữa đâu có
nghe nó hơi bị
nó chả được gì cả Nếu đúng là các bạn
không nên lo lắng theo kiểu các bạn khi
mà các bạn thấy có mùi vấn đề gì đó một
cái gì ở dưới nghiêm túc một cái mà kiểu
nó rất là quan trọng thì các bạn hãy
chuẩn bị cho nó rồi các bạn không không
cần phải lo nữa các bạn chuẩn bị tốt rồi
thì các bạn phải tư duy ở mình đã chuẩn
bị giao tốt mình đã làm hết sức khả năng
của mình rồi để nếu nó rất thất bại
thành công thì mình sẽ không ăn hạ coi
như là mình đã làm hết sức của mình rồi
mà đúng không Thì mình có gì oán hận mà
mình cũng cậu coi có thể nó không phù
hợp với mình hiện ở thời điểm hiện tại
cả nào nó vân nên là các bạn không cần
lo làm gì cả a ngoạn Tôi thường ai đấy
Kiểu mình đã làm hết khả năng của mình
rồi thì về sau mình trở nên hận đâu cẩn
thận đi ông Định cũng nữa đúng không nên
không phải lo gì nhiều cả ông cứ chuẩn
bị tốt đi là được Ông cảm thấy chuẩn bị
đến ngưỡng tốt rồi thì ông có thể nói
chung là thoải mái hơn không
Tôi thử là nói thế nhưng mà tôi
cho tôi rất là tôi không có những cái
thử Tôi Là Tôi muốn biến cái kênh này
của tôi là một kênh kiểu blog để mà chia
sẻ nhờ Thực ra tôi không bao giờ muốn
nhắc gì đó liên quan đến đã quá nhiều
người bạn thân cho cậu là hôm hôm nay
tôi đang định nói là liên quan đến hoàn
cảnh Tôi không bao giờ muốn đổi tại hoàn
cảnh cũng không ở muốn đổi tại bệnh tật
gì cả
Ừ nhưng mà Đúng rồi cũng có đang bị bệnh
một cái bệnh
vì nó liên quan đến căng thẳng và hồi
trước ở tôi tự tạo áp lực bản thân quá
hồi mà thi
Ừ thế này là bơ tôi luôn để cái tâm
trạng thôi Xong trạng thái thoải mái Tôi
không muốn kiểu tạp âm lực cho mình nữa
ngồi cho tự tạo âm lực bản thân mình rất
là nhiều nói cho tôi con người khác bổ
to ngay cả như thế nên là ờ nên là tôi
cũng khuyên mấy ông đừng có rơi cậu như
thế
mái thôi
anh em mới cốt mày cái vô Jack trong môn
thôi chứ chưa tự cố tôi trách to lắm
nên không biết nên cốt cái gì hãy cốc
cái gì mà bây giờ mình toàn nghĩ là ý
tưởng một cái nhu cầu gì đó rồi mình cứ
thử làm cái đấy thôi giống như Gần đây
tôi bảo tôi có nhiều ý tưởng lắm Tôi
muốn làm cái trang web chưa thể gái xinh
này ở trong cách chia sẻ nhạc movin còn
đây còn nhu cầu mà không nếu mà ông thực
sự không nghĩ là ý tưởng như ông có thể
hỏi người xung quanh có nhiều ý tưởng
cho ông làm
Bây
giờ muốn bổ sung kiến thức về cấu trúc
dữ liệu thì tìm tài liệu ở đâu
Cái này sao ông cha mạng thôi nhưng mà
nên cha bằng tiếng Anh nhá và ông phải
đọc tài liệu tiếng Anh dần dần ông sẽ
tìm đúng rồi người
nói chung là người khôn ngoan hơn nhau ở
cái việc theo tài liệu nghe rõ không
biết gợi ý ông nhé Chuẩn nữa à
hai thí nghiệm đi khi đi phỏng vấn á Ờ
tôi bảo rồi đấy ông tự tin này kết hợp
được với ông cũng phải tính trước vài
cái câu mà họ sẽ hỏi này đấy chứ Tôi
chẳng biết có kinh nghiệm thì anh đã
ngoài việc không chuẩn bị thôi
về cách luyện tư duy thế nào ạ Ở đây có
một câu rất hay ở tôi không hẳn là tôi
biết luyện tư duy lắm bởi vì ở tôi hồi
trước của tư tưởng ai chơi Mày cài game
không phải game chỉ hướng dẫn giải trí
Liên hình mà tôi thường hay chơi game
mấy kiểu gen Nó gọi nó không có bổ gọi
là có bổ một tí để cho tránh việc là
mình lãng phí thời gian vô bộ hãy gọi
hết tôi xem phim thưởng phim của Tí Động
não đi khởi nghĩa lại một cách mình rèn
luyện gì đó được phía xa còn về cách
luyện tư duy thì tôi nghĩ à
ờ ờ
về cách luyện quán điểm thì rồi nằm rõ
hơn đón trẻ để Ông nói chuyện với nhiều
người đặc biệt là con gái con gái mỗi
bạn là một cái tư duy một sẽ được bắt
trường riêng ông ông nói chuyện được với
rất nhiều con gái tôi khẳng định nữa ông
một ông như đa cấp
em có tí đóa hoa nữa và ông sẽ có rất
nhiều góc nhìn đấy
cả ông chỉ có thể là kéo đã có có trên
mạng có nhiều lắm trên mạng lại có rất
nhiều cái bài tập luyện tư duy lôgic
châu Âu
anh
em có tiếng Anh và tiếng Hàn nhưng mà kỹ
năng mềm cực kém ở thì mình biết được
điểm yếu Mình ở rồi và nếu mà em vẫn
muốn hướng đến làm thành con người cho
rằng nói chuyện thú vị hay gì đó Nhớ trả
lời em sẽ phải tiếp xúc và theo dõi
những người kiểu tương tự thế và phải
thực hành nhiều kỹ năng mềm này nó nhưng
phải càng nhiều và phải mặt cũng hơi dài
một tí của bia sau những lần thất bại mà
ông nạc nhanh thì không ông không luyện
được kỹ năng mềm đâu mặt trời chứ
Việt Nam đang yếu không ở
cho tôi lại nghĩ ngược lại đấy được cái
ngành Công nghệ thông tin ở Việt Nam rất
là phát triển và giữ là ổn rất nhiều
người đang chia sẻ các thứ thứ tôi thấy
rất ổn nhưng mà hiện tại nó cũng có một
tí gọi ở bão hòa theo kiểu là là
nhiều người dùng chia sẻ quá nên thành
nghe cái tài liệu nó không chất không
được chất làm nữa rất nhiều ong kiểu Dạ
vẫn muốn lấy thành tích đã bị ông lấy
điểm hình cái xanh diễn đàn chia sẻ mà
còn đây tôi bảo ấy bị vibro này kiểu
chiến này có rất nhiều bài cũng rất là
hay vẫn còn rất nhiều và rất hay nhưng
có rất nhiều bài cậu dạng đúng rồi dịch
từ Google dịch đúng kiểu copy từ trang
chủ trong dịch về đây mà không phải một
người mà có nhiều người làm thế trưng
bày nhiều lắm nên thành ra tôi phải dùng
từ bỏ nhà em kia để chọn lọc ra cái tài
liệu của bây giờ nó lại hơi khó à Còn
nếu mà ông Lọc ra được Lý do ốm nhưng mà
thực ra là mình vẫn nên thưa hướng là
đọc tài liệu mới nhanh hơn
thế khi đi sinh nhật trong ngành này
không anh tờ tùy theo công ty ông hướng
đến đúng không
để tui hôi mà thực ra thì tôi bảo rồi
ngày này sẽ chỉ cần là ở đọc được tài
liệu
ạ Và
nếu mà ông làm cho công tí nước ngoài sẽ
cần thêm thôi ở trong chai là Google bắt
buộc rồi
muốn làm phụ trách để cống hiến cộng
đồng lập trình Việt Nam thì nghe đủ to
rồi nhỉ đúng rồi
ở động cơ đóng góp cộng đồng hoặc giả
Hồi trước Và tôi tưởng đóng góp trong
như tìm công ty
chia sẻ trong đấy ông sẽ được tương tác
khá cao kết hợp việc là nhiều người biết
đến ông
ở thời tiết ạ
ờ ờ
được thứ mình thích mà Đúng rồi Tuổi Trẻ
mình nên cứ trải nghiệm đi để về sau
mình sẽ không làm lo gì cả Mình sẽ không
gặp dám à hay là nếu mà hồi trước không
đắn đo gì cả ờ
ý mình muốn học
ở cốt điều khiển và định hướng ra sao và
chuẩn bị à
Ừ ông cha dốt nát nhá Không có chả lốt
Mác
à à
à Xong rồi đây ông cha cái này số ông
muốn làm cái ngôn ngữ gì Ông bấm vào đây
để tiếp tục nhá đấy Ờ
khó hay Chấp nhận đi làm Lắm đúng thứ a
nếu mà giả sử mà Ông làm ông bị kiểu hơi
bị chậm quá thì nếu mà đến like gì nhiều
con nhận ạ ạ hơi tệ Nhưng mà thực ra Tùy
công ty ấy và ông thầy làm phim em cũng
được là xử thế không sao cả
Nhưng mà đúng chậm trong bất kỳ ngành
nào mà chậm quá thì ra là không tốt cả
thế
Nói chung là cái đấy cần phải cải thiện
thôi
khi
cài đặt trình độ như thế nào hay tích
lũy kinh nghiệm kiến thức đến đâu để làm
được các Bích tách như Google à
gọi là mà Google là hiện tại Tân bọc
những cái bài Thực ra nó cũng có kiểu từ
cựu nhân viên Google mà thực ra Google
nó có những cách hạn chế không biết rồi
kể mấy ông chưa Nhưng mà còn về để làm
cho cho những công ty lớn thì hiện tại
gần đây thì tôi xem thử là nó không hẳn
đấy nó cực kỳ khó như người như mình
từng nghĩ nữa vì ở thời ra đã có người
làm rồi thì sẽ khả năng sẽ có thêm nhiều
người nữa đúng không ạ rất sẵn rồi thì
chị Xuka những công ty lớn đấy xảy ra
cái nguồn nhân lực của họ rất nhiều họ
rất nhiều ý nên là tính ra là ông vào
đấy Tôi không khó rồi Thậm chí đã hồi
trước tôi từng xem này kiểu ví dụ là
kiểu mấy cái trường top đầu bên nước
ngoài ạ thì họ sẽ luôn tuyển 10 đến 15
Bạn ở trong những cái đại học tốt đều
lấy mỗi năm nhằm Chứng tỏ là kiểu dạng
nó không phải là kiểu ông kia rất xuất
sắc ông chỉ cần nói chung mà đạt đúng
cái gì đó ông có thể đã đã được vào đấy
rồi đấy nhắn được à nếu mà ông hướng đến
hẳn công ty lớn như thế
Ừ để làm gì chẳng để làm gì đã còn nếu
mà ông để cho nó oai Vân thì có nghĩa
không lên còn nếu mà ông nghĩ rằng là
làm cho môi trường nó sẽ rất là tốt và
còn Vân thì được nhà nước mơ rất nhiều
người lắm ạ thì ông cũng phải
sự tích lũy dần dần dần Tôi nghĩ là thế
trước khi vào làm Google không phải là
ông công ty đầu tiên muốn vặn đặt chân
vào phải lại Google thì tôi nghĩ à Nó
hơi sai ông nên kiểu vào những công ty
bé bé trước đã Xong rồi ông có kiến thức
của ông vào đấy thì nó không sao cả
Không ạ nó ổn hơn đúng không
phong cách lập trình theo anh là đáng
học hỏi đi ạ ồ
từ lại hơi Mỹ nhiều nhất ở
Ừ tôi thì
Em thử ta là tôi không hợp tôi không học
hỏi phong cách à cách lập trình của
những người xung quanh thôi Đúng rồi Tôi
có để ý nhưng mà mỗi người được ra lại
học theo một cách riêng và phù hợp với
người ta hơn tôi cũng chẳng học hỏi được
từ mấy người đấy là cách học như thế nào
là tôi không biết huyện kiểu gì dụ là
tôi sẽ chỉ nói quay nhé
ở đó là vé Mạnh Tuấn không ạ Anh mẹ Tuấn
thực ra tự học về lập trình học với hack
có sự thứ hai người tuy học của FPT
nhưng mà rồi thường khá sớm và tự học ở
Trà tài liệu các từ anh đấy kiểu dạng mà
khả năng tự học ông anh đề tốt bởi vì
nhớ rất lâu và anh ấy đọc rất nhiều tài
liệu và anh ấy nói chồng nghĩ là rất
nhiều phần mềm Hồi đấy là để mà nâng cao
kinh nghiệm các hướng
giải quyết một vấn đề gì đó em
hiểu về anh Tuấn còn là một người mà hồi
trước là tôi từng bảo là Người thầy đầu
tiên của tôi ngoài đời
đá lúc mà tôi mới bắt đầu đi thực tập
thì anh đấy là anh làm ra trang web hả
Phim bất hủ đấy thì à
cho anh đấy Anh ấy học Bách Khoa Anh đợi
ở sông
tự học tết Nói chung học ở chiến trường
và kết hợp và tự làm những cái thôi
trách các thứ thứ A và nâng cao kinh
nghiệm và về sau khi mà tôi biết được
anh đấy là ví dụ Hồi đấy tôi bảo là
trang web ở trên công ty tôi đang chạy
rất chậm và nếu pp vẫn tiếp tục dùng pp
nó sẽ bị đoán khá chậm bởi vì và lót ở
servo nó rất nặng bơm Vân thì cách để
cải thiện thì mình sẽ dùng một Facebook
ra khu Switch và ảnh anh ấy kiểu lúc đấy
bắt đầu học Angola này đang vu lan nữa
đấy Anh học trong Đúng hai ngày hai ngày
có thể bắt đầu thảo rồi đấy thì hai ngày
đương nhiên là không đủ để cho ông nhớ
hết
ở bệnh nhưng mà quan trọng là có tài
liệu rồi sẽ giúp coi anh đi học cái gì
anh chỉ còn học qua cấu trúc và và kiểu
xem nó vẫn những điểm điểm khác gì Nói
chung vào kiểu nó có gì mới và điểm gì
không có so với ngôn ngữ cũ mày đã học
đấy và anh người cho đi học luôn
thì tôi nghĩ là cách học ở đây nó vẫn
chủ yếu là tự học và tự mò đọc tài liệu
các thứ tư để làm đấy thôi thôi không đi
là phong cách có gì khác nhau về cái
điểm đấy
vì tôi nghĩ à Mấy hôm trước thấy nói về
những cái kiến thức mà có thể nhiều bạn
sẽ cho khó bạn được không muốn nghe và
tâm sự thì họ thể nói chuyện tiếp theo
trực tiếp được luôn thôi nghĩ thế
Ừ cuối tuần mà lại cuối tuần được một là
đông hơn hay vắng hơn thì các bạn đi
chơi
ô ồ
Ừ đúng rồi Nếu mà Mấy ông so sánh với
những cái bạn thôi tôi hiểu và tâm lý
của ông Khi mà ông kiểu dạng và ông vào
với thằng bạn ạ Cũng hay ông cùng phe
sôi ở nhà ông bạn mình làm được việc ông
thì không Ông bị chậm hơn em ạ Ông sẽ so
sánh mình với những đồng nghiệp xung
quanh nữa những người cá thôi Đúng là
hơi tệ thật nhưng mà tôi bảo rồi đôi khi
mà ông chỉ còn quan tâm xếp vào nghĩ gì
Uh đồng nghiệp xung quanh thì lương nha
Mình không
không cản trở công việc của họ được là
mình cảm thấy là mình mình bỏ ra mình
người cầu tiến được mình chậm thì không
sao cả họ Đôi khi họ sẽ thường ngày ghen
ghét những người mà giỏi mình họ cũng họ
và ghét người gây Cần chọn cho mình chứ
nếu không cần sợ gì họ thì ra họ cũng sẽ
giúp đỡ ông và cũng như là cậu động viên
ông thôi ông không Không nên tự ti quá
ông tự tin quá đội Nó là một cái thực ra
tự ti
Ừ quan điểm tự ti Nó sẽ là một cái hơi
sai
ăn trái cây cái tấm trải á
chủ tịch gọi dùng thuốc túi cả tự đi Nó
là một cái tôi thấy một cái điện tử hỗ
trợ thế
Ừ ông đứng như tự kiêu quá một điểm
chung nhá tự tin thì tôi nên tự kiêu quá
1 điểm thử nhưng ý tôi là tự ti nó sẽ
làm một cái điểm thử khá lớn ở Úc Ninh
có mà ông lên Ông lên cùng tiến và ông
biết được mình là ai mình biết được mình
chậm kém thì mình sẽ phải học họ thêm ra
Vân thằng đang cầu tiền như thế người tư
duy như thế anh không mình không nên tự
tin nhiều bởi vì nó cũng mang cái gọi là
cái gọi lại cái năng lượng tiêu cực làm
ăn nhiều người xung quanh cảm thấy cũng
không thoải mái khi mà ông cứ Hơi tí ông
Cư giống như kiểu ở 2 chế bản thân nhiều
quá người xung quanh cũng cũng sẽ mặc
định coi ông nhiều dạng Ông là người kém
là không muốn giúp đỡ ông em ạ bây giờ
thế Em đừng có nên chơi bản thân nhiều
quá nhiều cá thế
em nói chuyện với gái mà được vào
fanzone thì có được gọi là hiểu không ha
pantone trong trường hợp nào Federer cầu
đó ông ngắn 10 câu thì bạn hãy trả lời
một câu a fanzone theo kiểu như thế nào
ạ
em nghe như fatboy nhỉ
ừ ừ
Mày không có điểm này nào nhưng mà chất
sắt nào tôi cũng trải qua nhiều mối quan
hệ từng nói rồi và
Ừ tôi không có điểm rồi fatboy bởi vì
với tôi con điện phát boy Nó là kiểu
dạng lại coi gái như coi con gái như là
kiểu đồ chơi xong rồi chơi đùa con xúc
các bạn đấy Không tôi thế tôi bị chơi
đưa cảm xúc mới đúng là kiểu dạng này à
Ừ tôi luôn tôi luôn nghiêm túc trong các
mối quan hệ Tôi không nghĩ là rồi sẽ
thuộc cái dạng đấy
à à
Ừ nhưng mà tôi cái nói chuyện của tôi
thì tôi không biết được bây giờ mình nói
chuyện thì đang theo cái có khách nhà
tôi đang nghĩ là tôi đang tự tin à và nó
hơi tí giống đa cấp thôi
khó thì nó bình Lương cao không có quan
điểm này đi
em còn dễ thì không đến lượt ông nghỉ
anh ạ
Ai có kinh nghiệm gì trong việc D học
cái kia là gì nhỉ
data-size Mà tôi chẳng biết rồi đây Cái
gì quá Ừ để ra à
bác em thì khi em sang bác thì sẽ như
thế nào ạ Ông cứ học ở khoa cơ bản của
tôi nó cũng chiên được bác nhiều hơn ông
cảm thấy ông có phù hợp với bác không
ngừng sẽ tự cân nhắc sau nhé rồi nên
theo Dead Hãy để bố ạ Nó đâu phải theo
đẹp đã rồi mới kiểu đấy chứ nhỉ
anh em nghĩ mình
chị sẽ lại là giống yên tâm và kiến thức
phân đen của mình sẽ không đeo dụng này
nào thật ra thì nếu mà ông vẫn muốn giữ
cái file của ông Hiếu là phương sách
thôi ngoãn sách mà biết tí về quan em
chỗ chị nữa thì lương sẽ cao đấy
anh em mới ra trường
đi học thì học A B C
nhưng vào làm hiệu xz cảm giác không cho
nổi cái nào cải thiện không Cái này đa
số thôi Thôi chả nó học kiến thức con sẽ
khác với cậu đi đi làm nên là mới có
khái niệm vectơ trong mỗi chuyến link
hữu hiệu nhà chắc chắn nó thời gian đầu
nó bị ngộp chắc chắn nổi bất kỳ hại thế
thôi Chỉ có con nhà người ta để họ sẽ họ
biết họ đã tìm hiểu trước họ tự làm
trước các kiểu thứ họ đợi chọn hơn thôi
Thế nên là mới có cái vụ cái đầu án a
dự đoán triệu Chuyến sau của tôi ra đời
này có để cố hướng cho mấy ông dạng này
để mà đi làm không bị hiểu sáng ngược
cái như thế nữa đấy thế thôi
à Còn bây giờ Làm thế nào để cải thiện
thì chứ em giảm Ông vẫn phải đặt một cái
mục tiêu Nho Nhỏ Ông làm nho trước để
ông tự trấn an bản thân trước đã chứ hồi
đầu tôi từng bảo rồi tôi đi làm người ta
vứt sự tài liệu rồi em nói gì cả cứ học
học hơn một tuần là nhiều gì cả cho đến
kiểu tự làm một cái chỉ hướng là for xem
thêm sửa xóa thôi tôi bắt đầu hiểu dân
hơn thì mới cải thiện hơn
Facebook luôn á có trả lời là không Bởi
vì nếu thế thì ông sẽ chỉ biết ăn bộ
phim Quốc đấy và thụ động không hiểu rõ
được bản chất của ngôn ngữ lập trình
không
Ừ ông phải hiểu rõ
thậm chí Ông còn còn phải hiểu rõ bản
chất Lập trình là gì đã nhờ cậy thế
không nên kiểu nhảy cóc sớm làm gì vậy
tích cực cho cộng đồng là Google không
thực ra là không để chứng tỏ âm chưa tìm
hiểu sâu về Google thôi Google nó đúng
là nhiều người thân tháng không có khóa
Google Google có cái tốt riêng của nó
nhưng mà ở ra cũng có rất nhiều công ty
cũng có kiểu tương tự mà ông không phải
ông Cư hưởng đến một cái công ty to đùng
thế nó hơi khó bởi vì hơi khó Việt Nam
thật vì à Mà giờ ông phải ra nước ngoài
nữa kết hợp việc là ông phải thể hiện
mình rất là nổi bật so với những cái ứng
cử viên cùng trong nước nữa còn ở bên
nước ngoài công nhận là ông vào như tôi
bài thì ông chỉ cần học ở trong đại học
tốc đầu ở bên nước ngoài ra sự đối Việt
Nam với kết quả ạ Ông có hình dung là
bây giờ là sử công ty là nhấm yêu em FPT
hay Viettel nói chuyện những sinh viên ở
trong Bách Khoa chẳng hạn thì ông xã
Nghĩa là nó không hẳn cái gì rất vĩ đại
không phải giữ là to lắm đúng không
bạn hỏi đúng cái câu mà vừa nãy tôi định
Tôi vừa được hỏi đều trả lời đó là bao
giờ chính thức kết thúc khóa này à
ạ Bây giờ các bạn Tại nãy giờ đang tâm
sự gì đó thì các bạn thì không nghe
nhưng mà ba cái này tôi muốn các bạn tập
trung hơn tí nhá Ờ thứ nhất mà cái khóa
khóa chuyên sâu là này tôi đang cố Tôi
đang cố là sẽ cố xong trước tháng 10 vì
tôi để tháng năm rồi Tôi định tháng 10
sẽ sang bên FPT shop để mà dậy buổi tối
nên thành ra tôi khó mà kiểu duy trì
được về sau sẽ Lysine thường xuyên à
cho nên nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ cố dậy xong
cái cái
ngoài việc làm xong cái trang web mỗi
rồi việc làm kia thì tôi sẽ muốn dạy cho
mấy ông thêm cái trang web chính cái mà
tranh và tội từng làm nha trường cũ đó
là trang quản lý sinh viên không phải
lên lại mẫu quần quê ở Quản lý sinh viên
cho nó rất là rộng Nó quản lý từ sinh
viên quản lý giáo viên điểm danh thậm
chí ở Quản lý lương không khả năng lượng
không ảnh tính lương nhưng gần như à
quản lý số giờ dạy của giáo viên này
quản lý điểm này quản bia môn học vần
rất nhiều rồi xong rồi về sau sẽ thống
kê các thứ sinh viên là đủ được cái tốt
nghiệp sinh viên nào đang thiếu đĩa sinh
viên nào chưa độc khi nó rất nhiều câu
truy vấn mãi chưa về bạn đã bây giờ phải
gần hơn bố mới lành rồi đấy nhưng hai ra
là tôi muốn cho mấy ông làm cái đấy xong
nó cũng cần như hơi quá tải Ông mấy ông
à Xong rồi đấy đảm bảo chính ông Ngoại
trưởng anh cần như thế đấy thế đấy mục
đích của tôi hết cái hộp khóa này lúc
đấy tội chẳng biết là tôi dậy gì khó hơn
mỗi mấy ông đã nói tiếp theo thì cái mục
đích của cái đồ án Tôi muốn
ờ ờ Tôi muốn nói xong với ông
ở ngoài việc và tôi chỉ hôm ấy ông đồ án
đấy cái mục đích để mà tôi yêu cầu mấy
ông làm đồ án là gì Đầu tiên này ngoài
việc làm việc theo nhóm thì cần kỹ năng
thuyết trình kỹ năng kiểu để mà hiểu
được quy trình làm việc của một tạo ra
một cái sản phẩm họa từ đầu đến cuối thì
Hiểu Qua tìm hiểu công nghệ do Vân nghĩ
ra được những cái lý tưởng thì đó xong
rồi xem ý tưởng này xả kia không cho
nghĩ cách để làm vợ Vân lại mục đích của
đồ này thế không ạ Thêm mục đích của cái
phần mềm trong cái đồ ăn của ông là gì
có rất nhiều người đã từng
gì đặc biệt sinh viên từng nói với tôi
những cái ý tưởng gì Gió và tôi không
chấp nhận không được cái phần mềm đấy
cũng như là tôi cảm thấy phần mềm đấy
quá khó hay quá viền vong tại sao mọi
việc
Ê mấy ông phải hiểu được là mấy ông ví
dụ bây giờ tôi yêu cầu làm cái trang web
à
cả ngày hôm qua Sinh viên hỏi tôi đi là
con trang web quản lý điểm là chưa
Thì mục đích tại sao cái trang web phải
được ra đời có phải trả lời được câu đấy
đó
cho ví dụ Giả sử bị ông nằm trong cái
sống cái rồi ông thuyết phục người khác
dùng để trong cái như thế nào
ông ngoại Tại sao người ta phải chuyển
ra Ví dụ người ta đang dùng lá Excel thế
Đang lưu lại toàn bộ máy sao lưu lại
trong Word hay là thậm chí lưu lại trên
giấy tờ ạ Tại sao người ta phải dùng cái
phần mềm của ông nó có điểm lợi Ưu điểm
như thế nào so với cái cái trước mà họ
đang dùng cái ông phải trả lời cho câu
đấy Và thậm chí ở từ đấy ông sẽ đánh giá
được cái phần mềm của ông nó nó kiểu
dạng hả Nó đánh giá như thế nào dù giá
trị của phần mềm như thế nào đó chẳng
hạn thôi
ví dụ là hôm qua
Ý tôi nói với sinh viên Như Thế Đó là
cái đổ cái đồ ăn chuyên sâu này đồ ăn
hay này không phải khó hơn Cho đồ ăn một
là nó có cái mục đích là rõ ràng hơn sau
đó ăn bột đoán một nó chỉ được mà xem
thêm sửa xóa tất cả ông nhập vào cái gì
thì ông hiển thị ra đúng như thế Nói
thẳng luôn mà cái phần mềm như thế nó là
phần mềm vất đi Tại sao vì vì cái phần
mềm nhập và như thế nào in ra đúng như
thế
giống như thế này cái hơi Tính hơi buồn
cười tí cũng hơi mất dậy thì xin lỗi xin
lỗi cái tên trang web nhé Giờ đây nó
giống cái máy tính tuổi thông minh à
này nhập tuổi của bạn đúng không Đấy 17
18 ấy mà bạn nó mới dám tuổi rồi à
đã 20 tuổi rồi phần mềm thông minh không
máy tính tuổi thông minh thấy không chịu
đúng không thấy nghĩa là nếu mà ông nhập
vào cái gì nó chỉ là đúng với hướng nhập
anh đi Cái phần mềm này là có đánh giá 0
A gọi là chị không Chẳng đó chị gửi cho
vui Có người dùng còn
không nữa đấy
cho anh nếu không được chữa ông anh nó
sẽ vẫn kịch
đây nếu như mà ông sẽ làm ra cái phần
mềm
thì nó phải phần mềm thông minh là thế
nào thông minh đó là
khi mình nhập vào cái gì không phải nói
là đúng cái thứ mà mình vừa nhập về ra
chọn nhập vào cái đổ vào thì nó cần cái
đổ ra như thế nào ông phải dạ ông phải
giải được cái bài toán đầu ra
là thế nào người ta cần cái gì Ví dụ như
tao bảo là cái trang web quản lý điện
năng nhà trường người ra nhập điểm vào
thì để để ra cái gì không phải để ra cái
điểm người ta vừa nhập để thống kê ra
được những sinh viên nào đã đủ đủ đã đủ
điều kiện tốt nghiệp đã qua môn nóng
hoặc những sinh viên là đã trượt những
sinh viên nào chưa nhập điểm đấy ít nhất
ở như thế này thậm chí ở hệ thống kê
được ạ là lớp này có những sinh viên nào
chữa nhược điểm lớp khác đã nhập điểm ở
nhớ hơn nó này Thống kê hết được nghỉ
đấy đúng ạ
Hi hi nó mới cái phần mềm mà để người
dùng bớt lại nghĩ người dùng nhập và
những cái thứ mà người dùng đã có rồi nó
sẽ xuất ra những cái thứ mà người dùng
đỡ phải nhớ đỡ phải nghĩ gì cả nó sẽ là
được từ người dùng chỉ cần cẩu từ đấy
thì mà quyết định thêm của những cái gì
sau đó mà ông còn hỗ trợ được những cái
sau đó thì càng tốt ví dụ Giả sử nhá như
tôi bảo và hỗ trợ sau đó là gì Người ta
phải bấm cái nút mà thể tự động gửi mail
và những cái bạn mà thi trượt hạn để bạn
yêu cậu thi lại sang lạnh thế thì đấy là
một cái gọi là khi mà ông đã xuất ra
được một cái danh sách rồi Và ông sẽ làm
gì về danh sách đấy nữa là một bước thêm
trạng đấy một tính năng nâng cao nhé chứ
không chữ cái bài toán chuẩn của ông mà
chị thấy gọi là phần thống kê tự ổn thôi
Thì ông làm được thêm cái bài cái bài
toán đấy là ông Thành công rồi đúng
không ạ Còn mua khi mà ông
Ừ ông không giải quyết được cái bài toán
nào cả ông chị em giận à Ông nhập vào
ông ý đúng cái mình của Nhật
ý Thì cái phần mềm mà em phần mềm vất đi
Tại sao biết đi bị rõ ràng Excel Word nó
còn làm nhiều thế Ngoạ sợ mấy ông chẳng
có giá trị gì tràn đánh người ta dùng
thế thôi Đây thì cái đầu án 2 sẽ là cổ
vũ để cho ông bé ông hiểu được bài toán
nghiệp vụ ông giải quyết được bài toán
nghiệp vụ đẩy như thế Tôi sẽ cố dậy
trong bé ông điều này bởi vì rõ ràng là
không phải mỗi làm phần mềm đã có rất
nhiều người bây giờ thậm chí mấy ông
năng học nghe Chừng nào đầu ra của ông
là gì ông ông ông họ cho vui ở trong
không Ông cần phải có kết quả đầu ra là
gì đúng không hòa ngay trong buổi buổi
này được hạn ông xem cho vui giải trí
cũng được Nhưng mà nếu mà ông sau cái
buổi này Mông học hỏi thêm được không
biết thêm một cái gì đó ông ạ Ông thay
đổi làm cái gì đó Gì đó Ừ thì nó có ý
nghĩa hơn là tốt hơn không ạ buổi này
tới đây một tiếng thì ông thể cho nó
giải trí những buổi học cái khóa học của
tôi giận mấy chục buổi tôi không thể cho
nó giải Chị có thể mấy ông vẫn có thể
coi ấy giải trí của mấy ông rảnh mình
muốn xem tôi tôi khẳng định là cái mục
đích của cái khóa học của tôi thì tôi sẽ
không cho nó là một cái thứ gì đó kiểu
dạng Tuy là nó miễn phí nhắn trước là nó
sẽ có một cái giá trị gì đó này và mấy
ông mà mà kiểu theo được và làm được các
thứ thứ hiểu được cái mục đích và giá
trị đấy ông thì ông sẽ làm được cái gì ở
tôi tin là làm được gì ở tao hôn
ừ ừ
trả lời được 3 câu này nha Ừ
dễ nhưng mà thôi nào được Đúng rồi thì
ai lúc đầu chẳng tự ti khi mà họ không
có gì trong tay cả đúng không Thì cái
Ừ nhưng mà quan trọng thì có người thì
cứ mãi tư thế thôi nhưng có người sẽ cảm
thấy khó chịu và muốn thay đổi cái điều
đấy ngoạn có trả ông muốn thay đổi nó
không có đúng không ông ông sẽ bước tiếp
theo là ông sẽ làm gì đó
ừ ừ
tôi bảo tôi từng tham gia cấp mà có chỗ
nào thì ra để Ông hỏi tôi cái gì sẽ trả
lời thật với ông tôi con điểm cái ngay
không sợ chết đứng Tôi dám thi à Tôi sẽ
là thành thật nhưng cầu là tôi thấy à nó
không có gì sai tối lương tâm và chẳng
cần rất gì cả nghe nè thôi
hình ảnh sản phẩm hàng thật nhiều cái
ờ ờ sếp nói chuyện với gái
Xin
chào xong thì mình nói gì nên nói gì
tiếp theo tùy theo câu chào của bạn đấy
đáp lại là như thế nào nếu bạn ơi kiểu
trả lời rồi hỏi chấm thì ông sẽ nói kiểu
cái chuyện khác còn nếu mà họ kiểu dạng
chào lại rồi Kiểu biểu tượng mặt cười
hay Nhãn là niềm vui vẻ Vân thì sẽ kiểu
khác
phải đóng Donut họp lại không anh á
Ừ tôi có yêu cầu mày Ông đóng
ở chỗ nào đâu
em ra ngoài cầu mong muốn thi lại rồi
tính sau
ở tuổi chưa biết là bao giờ có buổi bảo
vệ lại thôi Cái đón một đấy chứ nói đùa
2a
ờ ờ
cho anh có nên quay lại người yêu cũ
không
Ừ cái này Tâm sự cái gì này thì có chưa
quan điểm của tôi đó là mấy ông quay lại
nhiều cũ nếu mà vẫn còn tình cảm thấy ở
nơi không phải vì cái mục đích kiểu vật
chất hai cái siêu hay đòi quay nhá mà
anh
quay lại thì mới ông phải giải quyết
được thấy lý do mà chia tay á do chia
tay mà kiểu nó vẫn còn ở đấy thì mẹ ông
chẳng còn lý do gì gọi lại làm thì thôi
từ những kinh nghiệm đi thực tập ở
nên tỏ thoải mái quá
Ôi không nên cất nhà quá với tình thế
không nên ờ
em ngồi xuống nhà ông
thể hiện mình cầu tiến thân thiện các
thứ thôi để kinh nghiệm đi làm cái thứ
xung quanh như thế văn hóa văn hóa chung
với như thế còn tôi không biết khuyên
ông nên như nào ở trong cái ngày này cả
cho tôi Tôi cũng không nhớ lắm mình cứ
đi làm cơ mà
hai thằng theo đấy bố và Ờ tối nghĩa là
ông có làm thứ gì mà ông cảm thấy ông
giỏi chứ ông không nên cậu chạy theo một
cái phong trào nó cả đứa con chào đá ốp
vì tôi thì cũng nhận rất là nhiều nhưng
mà chưa khi ạ nhưng mà bây giờ cũng rất
là nhiều không cần phải cậu à chạy nhau
một cái gì cả giống như tôi thôi rất
nhiều người và tôi làm cái bóp nhưng tôi
cũng chỉ làm quen thôi chả cũng không
sao
các bạn này cũng hỏi lại cái câu mà vừa
nãy bạn kia hỏi đó là à đây đây trong
này hỏi chứ học một công nghệ mới thì
nên như thế nào Tôi nghĩ à cái ruộng Gần
đây tôi có học thêm về ngôn ngữ lưu rằng
ạ Hay là hồi đó học lại đưa nhận đọc
những cái liệu xong rồi xem nhiều cái
video nên là xem video để cho ông đỡ bị
chán đọc tài liệu Tưởng thế rồi bắt buộc
không Vẫn phải được khánh rất nhiều thứ
để mình hiểu được rõ bản chất của nó nằm
ở trong web làm một cái phần mềm áp dụng
công nghệ lấy thì ông sẽ hiểu hơn
Facebook chưa ạ Không ông bắt buộc phải
làm từ đầu đến cuối hoàn chỉnh một cái
phần mềm gì đó thì ông ấy hình dung được
bản chất của cái ngôn ngữ đấy kết hợp
việc là hiểu được rộng hơn đây lập trình
với ông Sau đó ông học Facebook sao
ngữ gì ạ Hiện tại tôi đang dạy TP nó
ngôn ngữ khá là dễ ông có thể học phí
thon cũng được ăn một cách ngôn ngữ cũng
dễ nữa đấy và đương nhiên là cũng giống
như bạn cái bảo là nên học ngôn ngữ nào
đang tuyển chứ về một vài ngôn ngữ ở bây
giờ nó khó tuyển phải sở Ngạn tổ dlc + +
cũng nhận nó họ nó hơi khó một tí mà
cũng đưa Tuy là nó khó à cho sẽ cơ bản
để mà đa số học nhá Nhưng mà
ờ ờ học tiếng sau rồi đúng không nên học
cái đấy phải không Công ty biểu tuyển sơ
về cả
hơn so với lương thấp hơn so với ngôn
ngữ khác
anh nói chẳng nghĩ gì cả về lương tôi
thứ nhất vẫn cao và
tội biết rất nhiều người làm
ở tp luôn cao cao nhưng đúng là nó thấp
hơn so ngôn ngữ khác nhưng mà ông lại
anh bị nhầm xong việc là về sau mình chỉ
dùng một ngôn ngữ tôi vì sao tôi không
dùng chỉ 1 TP đưa nhờ tôi vẫn đang pp
bởi vì hiện tại mà vẫn là tốt Còn nếu mà
ờ ờ
à Còn nếu mà kiểu về sau mà cái pp nó
không mạnh không phổ biến nữa giống như
bây giờ tôi đang cũng bắt đầu phải vừa
pp vừa cả vi rét hành hạ bởi vì bị bởi
vì ra Speed đấy phím motospeed đấy nó sẽ
mạnh của con em ạ Còn nếu về sau 1fp nó
không được áp dụng nữa thì lại nhờ sang
ngôn ngữ khác nó như bình thường thôi
chúng ta không quan trọng vừa có ngôn
ngữ nào có hướng nội dung không phải
giống kiểu tiếng nói như kiểu là học
tiếng Anh rồi về sau chỉ nên làm tiếng
Anh không học ngôn ngữ khác không Không
phải như thế
gì cả lao để dậy cả chị
đây có dạy viết api từ trang web của
mình đi đến ứng dụng khác không Tôi sẽ
dạy về anh cho ai có trước hôm trước
cũng có bạn hỏi lại về lúc mà tôi dậy
cái ai bạn có vẻ hơi khó hiểu kiểu gì
tôi cũng sẽ phải dạy lại chi tiết về avi
thì mày ông hiệu hơn đấy ai à
25 tuổi còn chưa có người yêu ạ Anh ở
thì bằng tuổi tôi này
chưa chuyên view tôi sẽ không dậy đi vội
rồi không biết là tôi sẽ hứa được mấy
ông bao giờ dại view đây
Hiện tại tôi vẫn đang nhờ vừa làm vừa mò
nhưng mà chỉ mức tương đối thôi view bị
trên công ty người đã làm xong xử hết
rồi Mình chỉ có cốt gần giờ có cốt cho
sửa lại tí chạy được nhưng tôi chắc là
tôi phải làm từ đầu đến cuối rồi mới
hiểu được mà hiểu đây một chuyện còn về
mà dậy mấy ông ấy sẽ phải một hai cái
năm kinh nghiệm nữa làm sao tôi không
hứa hẹn được bây giờ
anh Cái này tùy đấy nhưng mà mình áp gần
đây nhất thì sẽ thả nó sẽ thường là ghét
à
còn hot nữa ạ Ôi cái này bàn tán lâu rất
lâu rồi hồi trước của pp nó nằm trong
top 10 ngôn ngữ ghét nhất cơ mà nhưng mà
bây giờ không phải mỗi TP bất kỳ Trang
diễn đàn nào giờ sẽ hiểu ra và scriptdir
ạ tra thử nhé
Java Script đẹp
hồi nãy y này lại đúng không thon của
mấy ông có này thằng ngôn ngữ nào nó
không có đăng bài I
khi người ta gọi là nó giống như bức khi
cấy
Fan và antifan thôi người nổi tiếng là
sẽ bị chẳng có cả hai cả antifan cả van
sẵn rồi
em đang có kiến thức kiến thức kia Cái
Nước Văn em cơ bản mà chỉ có bằng trung
cấp người ta có nhận không à
khi bé nhận bây giờ tôi bảo ấy thường
người ta ngoài nhận về cái kinh nghiệm
thực tế người ta còn hỏi qua vài câu hỏi
phỏng vấn về tư duy của ông nói tư duy
của ông nhóm có tí Tư duy và không có
đam mê ra công ty nó nhận và công ty nạo
sẵn sàng trên Ninh thôi không Không cần
phải kiểu quá sâu kiểu dạng kích thước
gì đó nhiều ông có kiến thức sâu quá và
tư duy ông lệch không đào tạo được thì
lúc đấy loạn
tôi sẽ
ờ ờ trả lời con này vừa nãy có bạn hỏi
mà bà cái khóa học chuyên sâu của mình
không có bài tập ạ Thì thực tế là là các
bạn bây giờ sẽ cái cái tôi đang dậy thì
đúng là các bạn mà nghe qua thôi các bạn
sẽ không còn nhớ được các bạn cùng lắm
là về sau kiểu nhớ là mình tự dậy ra đấy
thì các bạn có thể nhớ từ khóa này về
sao cho tài liệu chứ không cần phải tra
cái video cũ của tôi làm gì cả à
Ừ thì các bạn nên tự làm một cái parody
Tôi đang hướng đến mấy ông là bây giờ
làm đồ án mà không làm hình đoán đăng ký
làm đồ án Còn nếu ông không thích đăng
ký đồ án của tôi chứ không phải tự làm
một cái vagex đi chứ không không thể làm
à Ở cứ xem video tôi cho vui nó không
đem lại ý nghĩa gì cả không đấy mẹ nhiều
kiến thức gì cả mà quên nữa ông phải
thực hành không nhớ ai
em
hết câu hỏi rồi à
duy khi đi phỏng vấn
có gì chẳng biết tôi gì nữa nhé
đôi khi ở những cái hỏi về luồng xử lý
thôi luồng xử lý Giả sử với mẹ đang
tùy tùy em hướng đến mà em làm em à
khi làm tủ lạnh là làm bát làm phân làm
gì đó hay là người ta hỏi thì biết cho
ta cũng được Bây giờ có một triệu người
dùng cùng truy cập vào cùng một lúc để
em giải quyết bài toán như thế nào sẽ
nặn Thế em có rất nhiều cái nó là hỏi
vừa vừa hỏi kiến thức Anh xử lý cho toàn
nhà vừa hỏi cách tư duy của em xử lý như
thế nào nó một cái mà ở
Xin chào dạng là người ta hình dung được
là PR có một cái vấn đề gì đó anh chưa
từng nghĩ đến
chưa biết câu hỏi mà đúng không Thì em
em thấy có vấn đề như thế thì em cách
giải quyết vấn đề của em như nào thì đấy
là tư duy thế thôi à à
cách tạo nhóm Facebook Thảo luận không
ấy không bao giờ tôi có cái kênh server
ở trên discord đi tôi thấy rằng nó tiện
hơn Facebook mày nó chia nhỏ danh mục ra
là ông thể trao đổi trong đấy nó tiện
hơn
thế nào Vậy ah ông đang hỏi tôi không
ô ô ồ kìa thôi à
ạ Bây giờ tôi đang vẫn trong trạng thái
ở kiểu dáng thích ăn xong rồi buồn ngủ
thì cứ ngủ anh không buồn ngủ à Nói
chung là tôi sẽ không làm việc nhưng mà
tôi đang mệt thì Tôi đâu muốn như thế
không trung tâm trạng thoải mái mình sẽ
ngồi làm việc tự nhiên à Nhiều người sẽ
hiểu à
có nhiều người sẽ hiểu thế là ta chẳng
mưa to làm đâu mà không tôi đam mê ngày
ngày Thành ra vẫn có rất nhiều thứ là
giận hàm là cá thứ đấy cũng chính là tôi
bảo ông phải đam mê chứ nếu đam mê về
tiền ra rất khó Ông cài như thế trừ khi
làm ông bị thuốc sắp hết tiền thì không
phải vào mồi gì đâu mà làm thôi
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
Ý tôi nói không thì chắc chắn ở sợ tấm
gương xấu mày ông ngủ Nhưng mà nếu mà để
mà nói tôi tập thể dục vì tôi thích
tôi đi tập võ và để nó dẻo dai Tôi không
thích cái gì mà lắm dẻo dai khỏe khoắn
và nó kiểu nhanh nhẹn cùng các để tôi
hướng đến cũng không phải người đô con
tôi hướng đến thu sinh tôi sẽ hưởng đến
nhiều đấy là tôi sẽ Tôi thích bơi cái
đấy tốt à
ờ ờ
thời gian speak nản quá đúng ngoài rất
nhiều người thầy cô gia Swift làm đến
tôi hiện tại tôi làm là xứ từ lâu rồi
tao vẫn thấy có nhiều cái nó khó chịu
nhưng mà
cái này là chung rồi Nói chung là lập
trình sẽ có rất nhiều cái làm quan trọng
là khi mình
đã xử lý được nó mình cảm thấy kích
thích mình có hướng làm tiếp thấy không
thôi
nhiều nhiều cực
e3z 34 cái pass Vô trách ở quá ngon rồi
ờ ờ
em làm Park builder bằng Vario
the best user của ông kiểu giống kiểu a
good Faith không y hình dung gì ông lắm
nghĩ tôi định tháng 10 này tôi sẽ còn
bay vào trong Sài Gòn để làm buổi
offline
ở trong Sài Gòn
trước khi mà tôi chính thức về bên FPT
Shop phải dậy thì bởi vì tháng 10 cũng
sinh nhật của Duy tím community mà Thì
thì
tôi cũng nghĩ có khi là tôi vào đấy tôi
mở buổi offline cho
lớp mình hoặc là lớp mình thì đi ngay
vào trong buổi offline dự tính với kia
nói chung mà ờ
anh nói chung mà tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ
cả cấm nhắc về vụ đấy
ở đầu tiên là tôi cân nhắc lại vụ
offline uting committee trước
Ừ vợ ở Nếu mà Mấy ông thể
nếu mà đi chung trong buổi họp đấy thì
nó cũng thử ta Nếu mà đi chung cho buổi
họp đấy chắc chắn là thì mình sẽ không
chứng mấy giờ gặp nhau thôi mình chẳng
nói chuyện được với nhau nhiều nhỉ bộ
phía buổi đánh sẽ ở lớn cậu trăm hơn 200
người chẳng hạn sẽ rất là lớn ở có bổn
tổ chức buổi rượu được mấy ông và tôi
định khám người tôi vào tôi định và lấy
nghĩa là 2 tuần cơ giờ rất thoải mái ở
mình thì tổ chức buổi Diệu được nhưng mà
tôi không biết được số lượng sinh viên
của tôi có đủ đông ở trong đấy không
có đủ Đông dạy cho ma sói vẫn đam mê mà
soi Nếu không phụ nữ tôi sẽ là mày không
chơi ma sói sao ạ
nghe tiếng Anh của anh thế nào ạ Ở
Ê hồi trước tôi tiếng Anh rất tốt nhưng
bởi tao còn thì không phải thi nhà tôi
từng học ở trong khóa khóa luyện thi
Ielts học cho vui thôi
ờ ờ
phát âm gọi E
Ê mấy ông xem thì hỏi tôi phát âm tiếng
Anh rồi Mày không biết rồi Tôi đọc được
tài liệu tôi gõ được cho ngôn nghe nghe
tôi nghe cháu Ổn nhất về có xem nhiều
phim
yêu mà sao thức xuyên đêm đêm đêm nào
rồi xả thức xuyên đêm tôi thức suốt rồi
sao đâu thức đêm để làm việc tổ chức
chưa Rồi làm Bất kể ngày đêm cũng suốt
rồi tôi tôi không đến Như mấy ông đó
khi con làm chỗ không ngủ theo kiểu là
tận nhà 1 2 2 ngày thì đó không Tôi bảo
tôi sẽ luôn để cơ thể mình thoải mái
mệt quá thì mới ngủ bởi Việt cái ngành
này là khó một cây được mấy ông đừng có
ham Cài đặt Đấy nó chỉ hại sức khỏe kết
hợp việc cả cốt của ông không được minh
mẫn rồi ông cứ mệt không phải nghỉ sau
đó gì nhỉ Sao mà tâm trạng thoải mái ông
lại ngồi cây thì nó mới cậu cốt ông mới
chạy được nói thế là tôi nhiều lúc tôi
ra ngủ Tôi nghĩ là ý tưởng tôi bận thì
cho ra nhưng mà còn hơn là cái ông nó
cắm đầu làm nên tụi nó chỉ giáo lỗi thôi
forex nên viết cái gì phần giới thiệu à
Ừ tôi từng dậy mày ông cách viết CV mày
nghỉ à Nhưng mà tôi đi nó lại về cách
viết CV về viết về phần forex rồi chưa
ngờ nó lại nha Thì cái khi mà ông biết
là ông làm một cái dự án gì đấy
thì ông không chỉ nên là kiểu làm đầy đủ
tính năng thêm nữa xóa không không phải
nói là ông đã giải quyết những bài toán
nào
và nó đem lại được những kết quả gì
chẳng hạn thế không nói cụ thể hơn bên
sau ông Hiền nó cụ thể hơn là nó có thể
áp dụng trong những trường hợp nào có
vân vân được nữa càng tốt
có thể nói cụ thể hơn thì giống như được
là
ở lại cái
áo lẫn cả học hỏi được thêm từ gì từ
những cái dự án này nữa ngủ ngon đi
thích rượu bia lắm không chơi đồ kích
thích cho dù là tính cách của tôi thì
lại rất là thoải mái mấy ông rủ tôi đi
chơi gì cũng đi à ngày ông chủ tôi đi
nhậu tôi sẽ mồi rồi tôi đi hát thì tôi
rất thích hát rồi đi ba vũ trường tôi
thích thích nghe nhạc mình đây nhờ thích
nghe nhạc sôi động quá không ăn nhưng mà
có nhiều tôi Tôi thích đi quần mà không
thích đi qua đêm cũng được chiều hết
nhiều mà tôi không chơi với kích thích
những cái gì mà hại đền đó thần kinh tư
duy Tôi sẽ không Và thật là nó không tốt
đẹp gì cả để hậu quả không tốt đẹp gì cả
nên tôi sẽ không chơi mấy cái đấy thôi
Còn mấy ông rủ tôi đi chơi tội rất thoải
mái
Anh đuổi tôi quan điểm là người nói
chung là mình phải làm được và chơi được
người mà chỉ làm thôi thì cuộc sống cả
nhà không vui còn người chị chơi thôi
thì nó hơi bị hại nên nói chung làm được
Chơi được 52 ờ
thân ạ Vì sao cá nữa tôi cảm thấy không
hài lòng thì bạn hơn tôi sẽ cải thiện nó
tự nhiên là đến bây giờ vẫn nhiều cái
chưa cải thiện được nhưng mà
cách chọn ngày cưới tại thời điểm hiện
tại tôi vẫn khá tự tin và bản thân mình
đang tốt dần lên rồi nên là tôi cũng
không không có một cái điểm thì đó mà
mình
cực kì ghét ở bản thân không có
đừng có viết tắt nữa Mấy ông đấy ở dưới
tao rồi bắt tôi đón chịu
kể từ sau Dù mấy cái từ mấy ông kết thỏa
thuận sang hiểu luôn
lúc đó ông phải có động lực và phải có
cái gì cho rõ ràng Nếu anh ấy làm cái gì
không nghiêm túc được không Hơi hư lắm
Ông có thể ép người khác làm cùng ông
kiểu thế sẽ ngã thì sẽ nó sẽ nghiêm túc
hơn
à à những kênh YouTube anh theo dõi
ý theo dõi từng chia sẻ nghỉ rồi mà
hài hay và anh giải thích vài cái bìa
cho những người mà
tôi thích cách nói chuyện của anh ấy vì
cậu Dạ nhà mình cũng không chuyên giỏi
lắm Về cái đấy mà anh nói qua không phải
dạng như nhiều cái bình luận viên Đặc
biệt zota cộng đồng tô Seek cái này ra ở
nhiều bệnh viện Tô xích đã gửi cho tôi
từng nghe cậu dạng mà hiểu cả buổi không
bình luận gì cả chị cứ ngồi nói mỉa
người chơi player không thích tiếp theo
cái open-sans
thời trang hay đăng nhạc sống ở nhà quán
cafe giá hay Tôi thích nghe nhạc ở biển
đã cũ vì vậy studio
kênh thế gian gần đây gần một năm trở
lại đây tôi theo dõi Cái này có chữa
được không
i10 cho ra tôi là dân công nghệ nhưng
tôi không đam mê mình cái đồ con mẹ lắm
nhưng mà tôi nghe mấy cái này bởi vì à
Cách cách người ra giới thiệu một cái đồ
công nghệ cho cả hướng đến cả đối tượng
mọi người không biết về công nghệ cũng
cảm thấy nghe dễ hiểu cuốn vậy tôi học
cách đây anh Vinh Xô thì đi yêu nhau từ
vật vô và anh này nói chuyện cậu cái cái
cái
Ừ cái xả năng mà kiểu điện gọi là ứng
biến của người rất là tốt và anh ấy hài
hước
có nhiều người đương nhiên đập các bạn
nữ thì tôi đương nhiên đôi khi có nghị
cả một tí các bạn nam là sẽ thấy cách
nói chuyện anh ấy cũng sẽ gỡ hài hước và
cũng hơi có lúc hơi dùng từ vô duyên thì
cũng không hẳn lắm còn kìa Quan trọng là
mình nghe và người người cậu dạng là
người bị nhận có đáy giúp ở sự anh ấy
trêu đùa mấy bạn nữ ở trong khu công ty
ạ Mấy bạn đấy hoàn toàn cười thì nó
không được Tính vô duyên thì rõ là người
kia thoải mái rồi đấy mẹ tôi thấy hay
cách chữa ong mà thử nói đúng mấy câu
của anh đấy nói ở ngoài đường thôi tôi
sẽ ổn định ở ông có thể bị ăn tát chỉ có
vài cái thì đúng là nó Tôi không ngờ dám
đùa về đây luôn nhé anh đi tắm của nó
rất thoải mái nghĩa nội dung mà có nhiều
cái ông học được còn chưa Cái gì tôi
không biết được bao giờ mới học được
mà Chắc lại dài em nữa
tiếp theo bị kênh là người Cai ngày thì
phân tích em tôi tôi bảo tôi xem cái gì
đó tôi phá thích Phân tích
Con Kênh Ta gió này cũng ở kênh về nhạc
sống này nhạc sống này ai nói cho nhạc
cũ trở về thế Cái này 1kênh hài mà không
biết mà ông biết không Cái ngày hài cũng
khá giải trí theo kiểu là nó có tí giờ
rảnh mà
khi mở hài nhưng mà thì nhớ nó có phụ đề
nữa Nhưng mà nó toàn nói tiếng Anh không
phải hiểu cách đùa của nó phải cực tham
phạm nhiều ông
Nghe ca nhạc hội chợ từ nghĩa không nổi
không nổi lắm rồi tự nhiên bề nổi lên
cách Chóng mặt luôn cách nói chuyện hay
ý
ở Huế trên Mỹ clip cũ tôi nghĩa ở về sau
nếu tôi bí thưởng tôi sẽ làm gì
à Nhờ tôi có quay mặt từ đầu này nếu
không biết được
ờ ờ phê phim mà cũng phân tích game cũng
vẫn thích phim đã thử thật là tôi có rất
nhiều kênh ở đây ông thấy em nó có thích
như này em chỉ của tôi đau lắm rồi không
Bấm vào để xem xe máy mới nó vấn đề xuất
lên mình tiền gốc tới xem thôi cho chúng
ta nên chọn lọc không phải là chúng ta
thần tượng một cái gì đó quá chẳng hạn
giống như cái Ngày ấy ngày ông thấy toàn
bộ những cái bia rồi tôi sẽ xem rồi Tôi
chẳng có tâm luôn
vài cái mình mới xem thôi mình còn không
nên thần tượng cái gì đó quá
các bạn này bạn nữ sinh ở trên vật vờ
bạn này không phải là dân công nghệ nghe
cái review bạn ấy thực ra không chuyên
được công nghệ lắm nhưng mà tôi thể
thích của bạn này điểm Mày khát khá tự
nhiên
tự nhiên và khiến cho
tui làm Vivo nhưng mà người khác cũng
xem không phải vì bạn gái xinh
À vì bạn này không sinh xuất sắc còn
ngược như một vài bạn khác
Ừ nhưng mà bạn ấy vẫn có cách nói chuyện
hay
anh nói Trung Hà Vợ ơi cứ gọi là cái
duyên và bạn ấy cải thiện cũng khá tốt
Dần
à mình mình cảm nhận được cái việc là
người ta tiến bộ lên tốt
Ừ cái này là
toàn bộ video xe nổi
cái này nói qua việc đi du lịch các thứ
thứ tôi thấy hay ở điểm đây nó tỉ mỉ và
nó nói qua việc để bà về phong cách Nhật
đã có cách nhập này là khá là tỉ mỉ ở về
các dịch vụ có thủ thứ hai cách kể
chuyện lắm hoặc đang ngày mới Mình ở đâu
rồi nhờ bọ bọ kênh ngày
à à Phân tích hai nhà phân tích thì ít
mà kể lại Tóm tắt truyện thì nhiều
cũng được
chúng ta không có thời gian ngồi đọc hết
toàn bộ bộ truyện tranh đâu Cái này
tiếng Anh khá hài hước gỗ phong cách
kiểu nó hơi bị châm biếm mỉa mai tôi Tôi
thích hài trong tự châm biếm không thích
hài kiểu à
Ở chùa hay nhà ông Bích
ờ ờ
Đó là kiểu kênh của Việt Nam thiên về võ
thuật và võ thuật có tí hãy hứa trong đó
trong một vài video thôi Có phải video
tôi thế phá hay đúng thể xem cái kia đầu
tiên cho xem để khiến nó tôi theo dõi
luôn Kênh này đó video
giả lại với Diệp Vấn 2
Ừ ông thể béo ngày sang đây
ý nghĩa cho miếng sai rồi mà lại nhớ cho
miếng Center a
Ừ tôi hẹn tôi theo dõi rồi vì à
Anh video anh ấy chưa vậy Hay chuyển một
cái duyên cho dù à hơi mới dậy thì nhưng
vẫn Duyên và sau đó lại lại rất là tình
cầu sau đó hàng loạt những cái video về
lịch sử chính trị cũng ổn Tuy tôi tôi
khá thích về lịch sử
em cho dù là cho dù là kiểu thời tôi đi
học thì các thầy cô dạy lịch sử đúng
kiểu buồn ngủ và đọc đứng đọc lại sách
giáo khoa nhưng mà may mà tôi đọc sách
thì ra nó hay nói chung là tôi
Em rất thích lịch sử bà và Thư ca Tôi
nghĩ là ai cũng nên biết về lịch sử
không cần
kiểu dạng như giống kiểu xe khoa chúng
ta bên biết sự ta và các thứ thứ không
tôi không hẳn là hướng nên mấy ông ở
cạnh phải tìm hiểu lịch sử của Đông Nhi
là vẫn khuyến khích ở nên tìm hiểu lịch
sử nước nhà nhưng mà ấm chị ạ Ông tìm
hiểu lịch sử tìm hiểu văn hóa ông sẽ
hiểu tại sao dân người ta bây giờ lại
như thế các thứ thứ hai mà
bộ phim hài cái này thì là nó được quảng
cáo bởi kênh du lịch ở trên kia tôi mới
xem 12 video thì tao không thích cái
kênh này bằng cái kia lắm hết cái xem
không ạ ờ
ở đây là phim truyền hình mà tôi thế hả
cũng khá thích hài
a
trivial Cái ngày tôi xem video những cái
video đầu rất là hay
gần đây đăng hình như chạy cái bí ai vậy
anh này như chạy kêu với ai và Một ngày
đang bận 23 video về
anh rối gần đây thôi mà xem lại Nhiều
kinh khủng không biết được là nó nha
Nhưng mà tôi xem thì
Ừ tí là mình đi dạo gần đây bị lặp lại
là không phải gần đây nữa mà À có bị Mua
tít chung là kiểu cách nói chuyện nó
kiểu bị thế hôm trước mình thấy hài bởi
vì mình thấy mới còn bây giờ nó cứ làm
tiêu lại thì nó không thay đổi cái phong
cách thì mình sẽ nhanh xác khô Ngọn Cờ
những hình ảnh bình luận viên cho ta
phân tích về cho ta được cái này để cái
phim tôi thích
ở chỗ 22 cắt giai đoạn video gì đó Cái
này về típ Về gara đang em sẽ đi suốt
các nhà đầu tiên
đến bây giờ đi sắt à
Ừ cái này là của ông ấy một anh Ấn Độ
thế tôi thấy hai điểm kênh này lượng
người theo dõi nó cứ đều đều bằng Tôi ha
kiểu thế lượng Xem ấy hơn tôi lợn theo
dõi cái đều để cùng tôi ạ Bây giờ mình
cứ phải cục phấn đấu hơn anh ai ạ
Nhớ về sau này anh nghe sẽ thằng sợ hơn
bị bên này anh này Cài luôn luôn có thứ
mới ra video Còn tôi với sao tôi không
biết rồi sẽ ra cái gì
Cái này và
Anh đang chửi ở với 4 tấn ấy mà
thích vì sau thấy giọng hát hay thích
anh nghe nhạc nhẹ siêu nhân đến theo dõi
tiếng Anh không piano
Ừ cái này chưa tiếp theo của phim cà phê
chuyện nhưng mà hình như người đọc người
khác nên là thực ra không hẳn là thích
lắm à
Ừ cái này để mà xem
à à
ở các Player Dota Chơi game các tiểu
thương cũng được
Anh
xem tôi đừng quấy chẳng có cắt gì cả nên
thành ra là video video hướng có hơn nửa
tiếng là for game thì nó để nguyên nửa
tiếng power mình nó sẽ ăn cắp gì cả hơi
khó chịu một tí và nó nó dùng tool thì
phải để tự động tự động kiểu chèn thêm
cái intro cái gì đó để mà ra đây cái
video nha nhé người ta Vừa chơi xong tầm
nửa tiếng nữa thấy có video trên này rồi
Giờ tao không thích kiểu đấy
Ừ Nó kiểu nó tự lập tự động hóa tất cả
video này ông ấy không Nói chung là cái
cái kênh này chỉ để xem lại đó ông muốn
xem lại thôi chứ nó không có bình luận
gì cả nó chẳng phân tích rồi
cái này tôi nha Đang video Dota 2 rồi
Anh kênh này Tại sao tôi sẽ gỡ cái này
hình như là lần này tôi có xem cái video
gì đó làm về ẩm thực gì vậy
ở nhà tôi ở người không thích đồ họa Tôi
không thích ăn uống mà lắm thế nên tôi
mình gần mà nhưng mà nhìn cách chế biến
hay hai người không ạ Có thêm đam mê để
ăn
cái này vẫn là phim tôi thích kia thế
này mình zô
ta-22 hay tương tự thế deuce Mấy ông
không biết cái này thật ra hơi tiếc cho
mấy ông đâu như là mấy ngày
không ra video lâu lắm ba năm trước rồi
Nhưng mà cái này rất là hay về cái phong
cách cách vẽ ở chung nhà để kinh Hồi
trước Vlog nó cũng rất hay
nói chuyện à
không không châm biếm như mấy
à Mà theo cậu à giản dị hài á
mình nhắn tin inbox riêng nên bóp Linh
xem qua Ừ anh này là anh nghệ sĩ về
saxophone Tôi thích Saxophone
một số ta
ở kinh đô ta
đang về công nghệ kiểu cách nói chuyện
cũng được Mình thích được
luyện chó Thực ra tôi theo dõi kênh này
nhưng mà tôi chỉ xem một loại video đầu
Xem cách dạy cho nhé Còn về sau đăng ký
ạ lại ít khi xem
Ừ nhưng mà cách nói chuyện đó là dễ hiểu
rất dễ nghe để mình mỗi lần tôi cáu con
chó rồi tôi sẽ xem lại cái đấy tôi kiên
nhẫn lại bình tĩnh lại
ờ ờ
cách làm của nó rất là hay toàn đồ xịn
a review toàn đồ xịn và cách làm cho
chuyên nghiệp không thấy triệu
khi uống thể chém qua
mô hình ảnh
ở đầu tiên thì tôi biết cách này bảo gì
à Cái bạn mà thủ cái này bạn ạ Bạn này
chính ở chủ không biết nữa nhưng mà bạn
này là hot girl ở trường cấp 2 của tôi
bạn này xinh xinh mà đúng không Hình như
gần đây mình công khai nhiêu thôi đấy
tôi đã khá thích bạn này rồi nhưng bạn
này là con nhà người ta ạ Đúng kiểu con
này ra mình sẽ chỉ nên ngắm từ đằng xa
thôi Vì anh ai thử Hồi đấy bạn đấy Khi
ông Định cấp 2 thì mình đã cạo mình có
10.000 tiền ăn sáng rồi em ạ Bạn ơi bạn
đang đang bán nước hoa Pháp
mày nhìn đồ mà lại kinh doanh rồi và bạn
đấy là Bí thư Đoàn và đủ kiểu đã nói
chung kẹo đúng cho con nên người ta
chuyến nhìn thôi Thực ra là
nhiều lúc tôi cũng nghĩ ở đến bây giờ
tôi cũng có một ý định vị địa vị rồi vẫn
có thể tán được những con nhà người ta
kiểu ngay ngờ tôi lại nghĩ lại phải cái
hoàn cảnh bây giờ thì da mình không dấu
vẫn chưa đến nỗi hàng cọc tỷ phú ở cái
gì đó
những người bạn này gặp lại ra rồi Nếu
mà không phải chỉ cập nhưng mà nên là
nên gặp lại đa thức
không với bạn đấy nó ra à
em chưa được câu
À mà bạn ấy bằng tuổi tôi nữa chú chặn
lại méo hãy chọn với bạn lớn tuổi hơn
hiểu chỉ thường hay chỉ trong vòng 100
giây là thể giải thích qua cơ bản để cho
ông hiệu cơ bản qua một cái công nghệ gì
đó gỡ nhờ có nhiều video và dài hơn
nhưng mà cách nói rất là dễ hiểu lại ông
thể tham khảo
em có nhiều kênh hay nhưng mà đến cuối
ngày mới hiển thị ra như là ông nào mà
nghe đến đoạn bây giờ thì ông sẽ thấy có
giá trị có nếu mà Mấy ông mà ngồi nghe
tôi cái đoạn mà cậu ngay từ đoạn trên
này còn nhàm chán nữa được toàn theo sở
thích cá nhân của tôi cho mấy ông bỏ rồi
không để lỗi mày Ông nhé Mọi nỗ thôi à
ở kênh 2 phân tích về game cũng được cái
nhà không hẳn là phân tích game thường
nói tóm tắt hơn
khi đôi ta
Anh cũng ở da tự nhiên nhận ra mình theo
Toyota hơi nhiều thì chắc phải bị mất
cái này ở không biết mấy ông thích Lego
nhưng mà cái này làm kiểu thỉnh thoảng
làm những cái video cũng về luôn Lego
khá hay
à này anh này nói chuyện với đúng rồi đa
cấp này
tôi sẽ không mua nước ngoài tôi sẽ nghe
như nói à
Anh hiểu rõ xin này thì ra tôi chẳng
được xem video này của nào cây ngay cả
chỉ đại khái là
ủng hộ thôi
nhớ để tối hủy
nó ra cái này nói về công nghệ đấy hiểu
qua vẫn chấp cái về đó gọi trên mạng nếu
tôi không là mình còn trên mạng này xem
chẳng hiểu rồi bỏ em ở đâu nhỉ
gì đó
xem cho vui thôi được xem bây giờ mái
tóc này ra mình bao giờ mua mấy đâu ạ
A và mình mua mình con trai mình không
lên để xem đánh giá review mày đâu Cái
này thường hay làm cái cái video chót
kiểu dạng mà ở bánh đàn cái gì Bài gì đó
dù người ta ngàn nhiên
tôi Tôi rất thích xem cảm xúc của người
khác kinh ngạc nhiên gì đó vui vẻ chứ đi
đâu đấy do Tôi thích dạy học ở tôi sẽ
làm mới vui vẻ hạnh phúc vì đó Khi mà và
ngạc nhiên nữa thì tôi chỉ Ông này ông
cái đó
mô hình này có một cái xót con gái nói
về không phải nói nữa quyền anh nhá nói
cái này rất hay điểm như tôi từng nói
cái ngày không nói về nữ quyền ông kiểu
đấu tranh cho phụ nữ là đấu tranh cho sự
bình đẳng ngày âm Chỉ là ai giống ai
trúng phải đấu tranh kiểu lượng quyền
con gái hơn con trai tôi thấy không nên
không ạ Đấy bà đổi sang cho sự là con
gái phải mạnh mẽ phải tự lập có vân mẹ
ra hai mình cái này toàn những Nói chung
cũng là những bạn nữ gọi là gọi là có
địa vị nói này khác ôi
khi chúng em ấy kẹo Dạ nhà nữ quyền rồi
quyền ai hơn ai chịu không không không
em mới cay
thế này tôi theo dõi kênh vé code nhé
đừng bảo tôi dìm hàng mấy ông bởi vì sao
vì thứ nhất không có kênh pass Tôm nên
không thể gọi được thứ hai là
tình cờ khi ve có này thì họ chia sẻ vài
cái mẹo khá hay đứng yên tôi sẽ bỏ qua
những cái video kiểu dạng là chia sẻ mẹo
chỉ có trong ghép cốt nhưng mà cái sót
của nó ra hãy có vài cái được để mà nó
cái cốt nó cứ rồi
Ừ anh ấy nói khá hiểu về
cách làm à wordweb tượng Quan Âm
trọng xem cái cái cái hay là ra nữa thử
xem bình luận luôn à
đăng gì mấy nhưng cô Kỳ Hân Hoan này tôi
từng giới thiệu qua cho mày ông rồi
trên fanpage Facebook cái này là cái vẽ
về kiểu dạng là còn những trận chiến của
siêu anh hùng đánh lẫn nhau này cái đoạn
những cái bia thú vị nhất này những
video thì tôi không biết tôi không sao
rồi
mấy ông ấy xem thuộc nhưng mấy ông Cậu
dặn Phan Marvel và DC gì đó thật thì có
rất nhiều trong này nữa đại khái
nó kênh giải trí ạ
cho anh à
ừ ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra là ở
Ừ tôi cũng không hẳn là thích toàn bộ
video này lắm đấy khỉ ạ
Và bây giờ tôi thấy được vài giao thì
tôi thấy à
không không phải là kiểu cái gì ám giúp
được mình tôi bảo tôi không thần thánh
thần tượng một ai đó hoàn toàn cả
ý theo dõi anh Mạnh Tuấn và đến bây giờ
anh ấy vẫn chưa đăng bài buồn mà thật ra
tội không thiện không xem video nào của
anh đấy
Anh nhớ giọng an ủi rồi à
học cả hai
Nếu nếu thì nếu thì hai cách
ở lại là bọn kia
anh xóa bướm cái
anh
đi Shin Ae ra là hai một cái truyền hình
không biết được có dàn dựng hay không
nhưng chắc là chủ yếu Thực tế
ông sẽ được ngắm nhìn Golden jamsai kiểu
chửi và khai sáng cho những cái nhà hàng
đang Sắp sập và quan trọng và có thể
giúp thay đổi cuộc đời họ theo cậu hướng
tốt lên nhưng mà kiểu gì về sau khá
nhiều Thực ra là tôi thấy thời ra vẫn có
khá nhiều nhà hàng vẫn hiểu ở vẫn còn
cái tôi vẫn quay lại con đường cũ và sập
nhưng mà Cái quan trọng là tôi thấy
thích cái cảm giác mà kiểu khi mà ông
lại nói cho người ta hiểu người ta thấy
đổi xong rồi người ta khóc biểu cảm động
xông vào cái đấy Tôi nghĩ thật không ra
dụng đi
ờ ờ vv rất nhiều thứ trên này rất mạnh
Ừ cái này về Ok Lâu lắm rồi không xem
dấu hiệu
ở Huế thì trợ Poker nho không Hãy xem
cái này thì học vô cơ đâu vì thấy mấy
người trên này cũng hay
à à
ở Dota
ở kinh đô ta ở dưới buồn cười điểm cái
auto lại đi cho con cái không thể xem
ờ ờ
ở bên này xem để mà xem Ông này bẻ xưa
người khác có cách giải trí à
em thấy cảm giác Mọi người cảm thấy
thoải mái vẫn thấy vui mà
nhưng mà không phải dạng giống như giống
như vài cây nhà cậu massage massage mấy
bạn nữ sinh mà đây là khách hàng thật có
rất nhiều kênh để mà theo dõi
à à để mà cầu theo dõi toàn mấy bạn nữ
sinh
Ừ anh ấy anh ấy diễn có cái duyên cho dù
rất nhiều cái hay mà tưởng nhạc mà anh
diễn vẫn được đấy
anh em review tiktok cho vui à Toyota
em tin anh
ở dưới theo dõi cái này vẫn speaking bị
xóa
ở trong tất cả các xác tưởng tượng sắc
Việt và sắc hương nhất Thường thì ở bách
khoa toàn thư rồi chắc việc thì khá khó
Tâm gọi như sắp liên thì vì sao tôi biết
được là đạo đức giả tôi không hâm mộ nữa
à
đang ở trên dưới tim community
anh và tôi thấy à Cậu khá ấn tượng nên
tôi theo dõi
am7 thằng Đăng mấy thì ai ngoài vợ không
đăng mấy nữa
anh đăng cấu trúc dữ liệu cá thơm Nếu
thể tham khảo
Anh kênh razzil
nói cho mấy cái đầu
anh nhìn được người theo dõi có buồn
không à
thế này
tôi muốn học qua à
anh nói chung và của đấy tội tìm những
cái canh biểu virtus các thử đi học đấy
Không những vậy Lâu lắm hôm nay
U50 năng luôn đây nữa đây nếu không sẽ
biết là tôi theo dõi mày cánh
nhờ Magiê tiếp Hình này của chị này chị
này em hướng đến lại sách cơ tôi không
cuốn sách
tiếng chim sẻ đi nắng Lâu lắm rồi không
Xem Đế Chế
bộ phim hoạt hình phim hoạt hình này
châm biếm khá nhiều ống thể xem
lại What is vậy
Excel
nói chung và máy đồ của Microsoft sẽ có
vẻ làm để mai phố shop có nhiều cái hay
nhiều nhưng mà vì mình cũng chưa lấy Sao
không chơi mà cả hai thứ cả mình không
cần phải xem hết nhưng nói chung cần nên
biết để phía sau mình về sau cần cái gì
Biết đâu lại lên trạng này cha con
Có ai muốn cái này ở kênh nha ở đây Cái
này sẽ dạy mày ông ấy CF này nhưng mấy
ông muốn chuyển sẽ làm giao diện màu mẹ
đẹp cực và cốt từ đầu đến cuối thì cho
ông hiểu hay đấy
ờ ờ giờ review
Ừ cái này cái nào nữa rồi
không đăng mấy đó Xóa
liên minh rồi anh chuyển qua chúng ta à
Ừ cái này mới kênh ai như cái này kênh
cái ngày cũng về
xem này rửa xe
mà gần như là tôi không
anh không Sao mà cái đấy đâu các bạn này
mà bạn phải rất là đấy mẹ em cũng rất là
được
ờ ờ
Ờ cà phê liên minh
về mẹ bảo
cho xem nữa
Ừ anh tránh để bảo mật anh đầu lắm rồi
không đăng Anh đang 9 năm trước vãi
chưởng Anh có hướng dẫn hack khủng như
thế này đã em hướng dẫn này hack Mario
này
Ờ anh không Đang mấy đâu Thế ông theo
dõi chẳng để làm gì cả
ở Liên Minh bỏ
Ừ cái này về grab Hồi trưa tôi rất là
thần tượng của đã cốt truyện bộ drap hay
vãi Nó có tí thần thoại đi lại không Đấy
cái này cũng chính kênh của bạn tôi làm
dịch các thứ thứ hai về grab ông thể xem
minh nhạt nhẽo Bây giờ ông vẫn thích lên
mình à Nên bây giờ chị chơi aram khỏi có
mấy cái chế độ gì gì đó hồi nhân phẩm
thôi
lời thêm mấy ông cái này rất là hay về
thế giới động vật Nhưng mà theo kiểu cái
chú Phát Súng Phát mày cái mẹo thứ gì đó
và theo cậu châm biếm không phải châm
biếm nhưng nói kiểu ra hài gì đó Nếu mấy
ông biết thì ngay
ở đây cái ngoáy mạnh tuần này hồi trước
Đăng rất nhiều cái này đang ít hơn rồi
a cho rất nhiều cái nói chung hội Hồi
trước anh Tuấn Anh Tuấn hiệu Hưng nội
anh ấy ít nói nhưng mà người đăng lại
rất nhiều
Ừ cái này là kênh của thầy dạy ảo thuật
tối này
ở Liên Minh Bảo
nhiều highlight của Toyota bị bỏ rơi
tiếp Tôi rất thích cái in cho cái ai rất
là hay mà mình cho rất là đẹp
Ê bà lấy nhạc là nặng nền là We are
electric phối vào bất kỳ video nào cũng
hay Xem lại video cũ nhất để tưởng nhớ
là không biết có bị ăn mòn Quyền
Ờ Ờ bây giờ một tiếng 40 phút rồi Thôi
để mặc Quyền thì cũng là mình nghỉ luôn
nhỉ
ghép hại
em hết rồi
Em hãy Bây giờ tôi mới sang một cái
video thôi
không biết mày không có thích thì cho ta
không tạm bỏ qua Vậy ạ
cho tôi không nghe nhạc của định để kể
đến cây mấy của mấy hai bài tôi biết
thôi Bởi vì thử
k11 ông ở trên công ty tôi ở chung nhà
ông lấy nhiều người thường ai bảo là ông
này có tính cách và rất nhiều cái giống
tôi nhưng cũng có rất nhiều ấy ngược lối
ví dụ khá điển hình à cái giống tôi là
gì cả hai đứa đều thuộc da rất là trẻ
trâu cả hai đứa ngồi cãi nhau suốt ngày
nhưng mà cái trẻ trâu của ông đấy hát
chiều sâu của tôi tôi sẽ sâu và tội
nhưng mà ngoại hình tôi cận tri thức và
tôi nghiêm túc thì nước còn ông ấy sẽ
Châu một cách lộ liễu luôn ông ấy kêu ạ
dạng là đeo khuyên này xăm trổ còn biết
xem thủ không không biết nhờ ông ấy đi
phân khối lớn này xong rồi cho xong rồi
em chửi nhau với bọn trên mạng được ở Mỹ
rồi lên văng tục hứa đù thể loại ông cầm
Băng Tâm trong nhóm mấy lần để tôi phải
chặn em ạ
tôi thì theo cậu là lịch sự hơn các thứ
thứ nhưng mà tôi vẫn trẻ trâu theo cậu
là tôi vẫn có thể máu và chửi nhau còn
như thế có không hiểu dạng bốc đồng như
ông đấy ông ấy bốc đồng hơn rất nhiều
đấy Ờ
Ừ ông đấy à trên cùng công ty ông ấy
cũng làm lập trình giống tôi nhé hai đứa
đều là lập trình full sách luôn và
ông đấy nói cho ông đấy chúng tôi quan
điểm khác nhiều việc là không phải cứ ở
Dân công nghệ kiểu phải to trí thức kiểu
gì đó mà là ông ông đấy là kiểu Dân Du
cũng không học đại học thì cả ông ấy
cũng
ông ấy không học đại học cơ ông ấy quen
Anh Tuấn Anh Tuấn vậy cho trình ông ấy
tự học là chính đã thứ thế mà cuối cùng
vẫn ngon lành được Nói chung là vẫn làm
như tôi đấy nhưng tôi chẳng công ty luôn
thì ông đủ biết được à kiểu không phải
cứ phải dân Cậu dặn à Vậy nói chung
không đánh giá người ta qua vẻ ngoài
được nhiều thế cả hai ông ấy chưa cần
thuốc cá sấu đủ kia cũng hơi tị nạn được
tôi với Dung từ tai nạn thì đổi cái tôi
nó là cậu không tốt nhưng mà nhưng mà
Thì đấy Họ thích kiểu thế và và Nhưng mà
tôi thấy rất ổn
Ừ vậy thì tại tớ ổn họ vẫn ổn mà anh
chửi hết
ờ ờ
và đấy nhạc của đế cây nhạc rap cấp thứ
mà chúng vào cởi Android thì ông ấy
thường em ở trên trên
công ty những tôi có nghe được gì đây đã
lẽ Thực ra tôi sẽ hồi trưa tôi không
thích mày thì lại đấy ở gần đây tôi thấy
có vẻ nhanh hiểu thì cũng có vài bài
cũng được hả Thế
chờ Châu Hà Đông ông gặp tôi ngoài đời
rồi Có khi tôi chửi ông ấy
muốn chửi nhau mà nếu trong này gặp lại
khá thôi chị vậy cũng khá nhiều với sinh
viên của tôi Cậu là kiểu 22 thôi sự hiểu
Tôi muốn chơi gạo nó không cắt quá tôi
không Tôi không phải chữa bệnh cảm tích
cực từ kiểu trêu anh thấy thế còn à
khi chúng tôi sinh viên tôi đều Công
nhận tôi có sẵn sẽ sau đi theo thoải mái
vui vẻ cái đấy
hỏi nhất là biết gì về api rồi tối ưu
website bảo mật dụng gì và Vâng đúng rồi
ạ
ờ ờ
vì anh nghĩ sao về bài Tarot cái này đại
khái nó là bể ở tâm lý học kết hợp với
việc là niềm tin thôi mà giống kiểu đại
khái giống như ở kể cả về bói toán về ở
em về tử vi hoặc
cung hoàng đạo được ra tối không tin
tưởng Một cái gì ông chăm như thế Sao
tội hơn Mỹ hồi trước khám mấy tím khá
mới Tí nữa tôi đọc khá nhiều về tâm lý
các xu hướng nhưng mà
Ừ tôi không muốn là kẹo số phận mình An
Bàng cái gì đó số phận do mình quyết
định thì nha cậu không bờ tin mày có lấy
tuyệt đối cho tao không cho đi bò mấy
cái đấy
mà
Ừ tôi Thỉnh thoảng tôi xem sót của anh
độ cho tôi không thể gọi anh độ tôi
không thời gian để ngồi xem theo dõi bất
kỳ blocker là bây giờ cả
dõi anh hơn anh Ấn Độ và lấy một tí cho
một tí thôi Nó thỉnh thoảng thì nhưng mà
lượng xem anh đấy hơn
Hiểu chứ
ẩm thực ra có nhiều cái nó tôi không xem
tôi xem chửi hài hơn
tham gia nhóm trên thì có ạ ạ đội anh
Tuấn tạo Linh thôi Nhưng chịu
những người thích nghe nhạc buồn là
người như thế nào Ồ nếu mà ông hỏi tôi
là con gái rồi chẳng biết trả lời con
cái đâu khi vui không em là buồn à Công
ty anh làm về mảng gì ạ
ở công ty tôi làm về án thương mại điện
tử về sản phẩm ngắn
Chỉ tiêu này thì có hiến máu không Ông à
best bụng mà đặt cược với không Tôi
chẳng cho cầu Bạc Tôi không cần được một
cái gì cả tôi cũng không nạp tiền vào
lên làm đâu
khi sex
ông kìa hỏi tôi Có nên mua Macbook không
Ừ tôi đã kì thị đồ Apple ông không nên
hỏi thôi Ờ nhưng mà nếu đúng là ông làm
mắc Ông mua Macbook để học là trình thì
hồi trước thì tôi khuyên là không nhưng
gần đây mấy anh em ạ Ở trên công ty dùng
mắt mà bảo nó chạy về ổn hơn nên chắc là
ông thích ông thể mua
không theo copywriter cho dù vài công ty
vẫn tuyển và vẫn dung nhưng mà nó là
những cái dự án cũng mới giờ toàn dùng
during thôi
bậy đấy giống như là tôi rảnh Mấy ông
tối của băng mày đâu nhưng mà tôi cần
nghiêm túc của chúng ta vẫn nghiêm túc
còn lúc cật nhà chúng ta vẫn còn nhà thì
mới thoải mái vui
không ạ Chơi game
chơi game mà để giải tỏa thoải mái mà
anh nói chung là chửi bậy nó khác với
sát với kiểu dáng Ru nó đứng cắn hàng
quá là được à
lâu lắm rồi không chơi rồi ra luôn ý
đừng nói cậu mua một cái gì đó bị cho da
đầu không chơi không ạ
đ.dân IP không biết cài Win có sao không
cài Win nó dễ mà chỉ AK nên mackay nghĩ
thôi
anh nói chung à Đúng là giờ này đi không
cần phải biết làm này làm cái kia nếu
không phải trên một mình nhưng thực tế
mà nói thì là tôi cảm thấy là mình cũng
nên mình cũng nên biết để cậu là cũng
nên biết làm tối ưu cho máy để cũng phải
biết ram dùng cái gì chẳng hạn gì đó thì
nâng cấp máy gì đó không ạ Và nếu máy
chạy chậm thì mình phải biết được lý do
chúng mình mình nên biết để và để phía
sau mình cải thiện cho chứ máy của mình
cũng như là mình cũng phải tia học về
lập trình Nhưng mình phải biết về bảo
mật để mà tránh bị hack hành án đơn giản
như không phải đi hai người khác nhau
Trải đều bị hack ạ đây chứ không thì nó
bị hâm bị nhục phải dùng từ nhục đúng
bởi vì ạ Bây giờ giả sử mấy ông tự nhiên
mấy ngày sau tự nhiên đổi tên thành hệ
thống Messenger à
bộ phim thì có phải là buồn không người
khác đánh giá gì không đúng không nên là
thôi mấy ông à
anh không nên cậu để biết hay không gì
cả
thôi tao bỏ hôm nay chúng ta tạm ngưng
bé em nhé có gì hôm nay là buổi à tôi à
anh chưa nghĩ thì máy để cốt hạn chế là
tôi cũng khá bận vào vào tuần này để mà
kiểu
làm gì đó tôi còn chưa chấm đỏ ăn mấy
ông cơ làm cha để nhà để ba đầu thứ hai
sau tôi sẽ hiểu vào luôn vậy thôi chấm
lại con thứ Tư này khá mình
chưa vào buồng lại được song ca ờ
sao nó nhạt nhẽo hờ
Ừ tôi không đầu tư vào bất kỳ cái gì
mấy cái kẹo kiếm tiền gái hư đấy đặc
biệt mình cái Đau tim lắm tôi không đầu
tư là mày cái đầu cho dù có thích nhân
vật thì tôi chỉ chơi cờ bạc vào dịp Tết
cho vui thôi chứ tôi không đầu tư vào
một cái gì hiện tại ra
nếu đầu tư trạm chính xa tôi đang đầu tư
con như vậy Hãy dùng từ như thế cho đầu
tư thời gian mà Mấy ông bà nói chung mọi
thứ mấy ông trả đầu tư và những người mà
tôi cảm thấy à là không phải là vì sau
có lợi cho tôi mà là
mấy người đấy có triển vọng gì đó Bà Tôi
muốn thay đổi
tính tôi thế chả muốn thay đổi cuộc sống
kiểu cao thế
xin quẻ vài người mà tôi muốn
tôi sẽ đầu tư tưởng thế tôi không đầu tư
Ừ cái về vật chất tôi quan trọng vật
chất đâu
Ê mày định bảo Tâm sự cái hoàn cảnh của
tôi nhưng mà chắc à
em vừa rồi chào em mấy ông có phải béo
nhiều ờ
không muốn mà buổi sao tâm tâm sự đâu có
nhớ bữa mày tâm sự tâm sự nốt ai ai nghe
thì nghe thôi Ờ ờ
đề thi ở hoàn cảnh của tôi thì là gì
Ừ nếu mà nhiều người vừa rồi nghe tôi
không để vật chất chẳng hạn đặc biệt là
nhiều người gặp tôi ngoài đời chị sẽ
thấy hồi trước còn bây giờ vẫn thế sẽ
nhiều người sẽ bảo tôi cũng tự giống
công tử bột tham khảo là bởi vì ra tôi
khá trắng được thừa hưởng tới da trắng à
mà cũng ít làm việc nhà nó cho mà ít vận
động nên Thành A cậu trong nó yếu đuối
eo là không Mẹ tính tôi không em Nhưng
mà kiểu dạng trông hơi thiếu Sức Sống
thì thế
Em dùng thử nghiện thì không nên lỗi lại
béo hơn thì thôi không nói trông như
nghiện nhưng mà
à à
Yếu yếu thế
và nhiều người sẽ nghĩa là công tử bột
và đặc biệt là tôi tiêu tiêu xài nữa tôi
khi tiêu ấy tôi lại cậu ở tôi thường hay
tiêu cực Tiêu hoa cúc đúng nếu mà tôi
thấy là có những cái xứng đáng ví dụ ra
sự điền kinh á Ở
không Những lúc mà tôi không để tóc tại
Dầu Giây gọn gàng đấy à
từ điển hình là tôi mua cái
nhiều người vẫn cười nói tôi Nhất là cái
vụ ở tôi đầu tư thận á một triệu chín
mua cái áo chống nắng hạ có gì Cái đấy
xịn thằng béo đấy nó là những người mà
sờ xong cái áo đấy vẫn khẳng định ở công
nghệ nó sĩ thật nhờ tao cũng sẽ không bỏ
một triệu chín tôi mua cái áo cho Nam
bởi Hồi đấy là tôi đi làm thôi đi hội đi
dạy con nhận nhiều tiền
Ê mày có thể mua như thế nhưng mà kết
hợp được cả là thôi Tôi tôi nghĩ là kiểu
tôi luôn có điểm có tiền nào của nấy
hình ah Tôi sẽ mua cái gì ở xứng đáng Tí
nó có giá trị thì tôi không phải mua cho
có
Em ở chỗ nào Nam nhé tôi lên Tiki ngồi
chọn sắp xếp giá từ cao đến thấp không
hiểu Hồi đấy rồi toàn thế bấm vào sản
phẩm có tiền để mua nên là à Nên là kiểu
nó một cuộc khởi nghĩa kháng tự nhiên
sinh em với áo ngắn chuyện chị em à rất
là tốt rồi nó chấm nó chống được tia cực
tím nhưng mà giáo trong nắng bình thường
nhưng cả thích chắn treo kéo lại ông mặc
cho nó map như thế à
khi một thằng 22 tuổi
Ừ nó lo
đâu khỏi 22 tuổi đúng nhà
Ừ thôi đi Ừ đúng rồi tầm 22 tuổi 22 tuổi
cấm hay cầm 30 triệu trong túi quần
lúc đấy mua được khá nhiều thứ đấy
Ừ bia kẹo à
ở trường tôi không Không có khái niệm
chuyển khoản mấy nữa toàn trả tiền mặt
như kiểu cầm một cục tiền trong người
đuổi theo đuổi quân
Audio
tiêu là hơi bị thoải mái thì xả đi
31 tháng cầm như thế nhá chứ không phải
là kiểu váy hàng không à à
Ừ
nhưng mà trước đấy nữa Khi mà tôi không
kiếm được nhiều như thế Tôi đã tiêu rất
thoải mãi ngay từ việc đi ăn uống về tôi
quan điểm mà ăn uống cũng kiểu dạng nên
thoải mái không phải cậu bạn là mình ăn
về xem được cả nhưng tôi gọi đồ uống rất
thoải mái anh ăn nhiều người cứ tưởng
tôi giàu là 3 và ạ tôi đi chơi mọi người
cũng thương em thoải mái thật chưa Tôi
nhớ lúc vừa trả được cho bạn bè bạn như
thế nghe thành nhiều người sẽ nghĩ cho
giàu nhưng chẳng qua là tôi đó
em không mở để xuất đi tôi cả hôm nay
tao chả bữa nay hôm sau mày có thể trả
ra bước hạt cái gì đó thoải mái
À mà tôi không tính toán chi li gửi cả
có vài cái mà cho nó chị ạ
ở bài chụp cái gì gì đó thì tôi cho bạn
bè luôn chứ không trả hội luôn bạn bè
luôn chứ không phải được tính toán Long
đến rồi cả mày ra nhiều người sẽ Trọng
Nghĩa tôi mới thả ra em không Bởi vì tôi
từng Không có gì trong tay nghề thành ra
là thôi à
Anh không quan trọng vì vật chất có có
hai con đỉa
22 hướng mà mày ông Khi mà không Khi mà
ông từng rất là nghèo Khi ông có tiền
thì ông sẽ một nó sẽ không mở một điểm
nữa
em và ông xã cũ để khiến mình quên đi
quá khứ sẽ cay nghiệt những cái nghèo
cái đó gì đó nó quen con người như thế
có
khi người ta sẽ rất là ki bo kẹt xỉ tính
toán các thứ thứ Người ta không muốn làm
lại càng nghèo khinh cả nhà đói Vân Vân
còn cái đựng hai đó là khi mà mình đã
từng Không có gì rồi nghe nè Tôi sống
lại rất là thoải mái Tôi
tôi kìa tôi
Ừ thế nào cũng được kiểu kiểu như thế
ông hiểu vừa rồi bảo là tôi có thể kiểu
trả trả nhiều tiền như thế Vân đúng
không Không biết được lúc mà ngủ chưa Ừ
tôi chui xuống gầm bàn với ngủ không cậu
hồi mà tôi dạy học đi bởi vì trên trên
trường tôi không có chỗ nghỉ ngơi cho
giáo viên lắm chỉ có phòng giáo viên thì
kiểu đi như có bàn làm việc để làm việc
hư thứ có buổi trưa buồn ngủ quá thì thì
nhiều thì thứ tha thời gian nghỉ trưa
cũng nhắn nữa chỉ có một tiếng rưỡi bao
gồm ăn nhiều thầy cô đó đi Ngồi trà đá
không không ngủ tôi thì tôi muốn ngủ đi
tôi phải có sức chịu khó dậy
chui xuống gầm bàn nó ngủ ơi trả còn
giáo viên nào dám chui xuống các bạn ngủ
cùng tôi nói thẳng như thế
thôi Có người còn cười mỉm cười như thế
này còn tôi rất thoải mái sinh viên đi
qua nhìn thấy cơ và
khi tính thuế thì đó là à
Lê Minh Thắng mình thảm quan tâm người
khác nghĩ gì lúc đấy nữa ừ
nhà mình có dạng Sống ngay thẳng và mình
thấy cái gì mình làm được mình làm
Chúng tôi khẳng định tôi chịu được khổ
tôi là tôi nhìn thấy nhưng tôi chỉ có
họp
Ê bà tôi có thể sống nhưng môi trường
cái thiếu thốn
có nhiều người không vì thế mà nhiều
người không muốn như thế về sau
cách tải Thiện lên là tôi cái hoàn cảnh
của tôi như thế ông phải hiểu Hoàn cảnh
của tôi đã từng tệp như là tệ nhất đó là
tôi ở trên phố cổ Gọi cái mác gọi matcha
phố cổ nhưng lại rất oai Nhưng mà thực
tế là kiểu ông không hiểu được trên phố
cổ Nhà bận ở nhà vệ sinh bẩn Nhà rồi nhà
tôi không nhà vệ sinh cơ Tôi dùng nhiều
cái sẽ công cộng nhà vệ sinh công cộng
đấy Bạn tôi tuần Bào bảo nó là như như
vào bộ phim kinh dị vậy mà tuổi từng
ngày sống em đấy là tôi và vệ sinh ở đây
và tôi từng nghĩ là tôi không thể tiếp
tục về có thể họ nhầm Để sau dẫn vợ về
đấy ở đâu ở đây cũng là một trong những
cái động lực của tôi hiện thoát ra khỏi
cái gọi là
nội dung dự của chuột đúng đấy nó không
khác gì cả từng là tệ như thế à
anh và tôi cảm thấy tôi may mắn khi gặp
được rất nhiều người
Thu Hà Và thậm chí là à
Em à tối tôi bảo tôi
à vì nghèo khó như thế không rất nhiều
người Nó bảo bây giờ ví dụ không trước
lại có thêm một người nó khuyên thôi Bây
giờ ông đang dạy online như thế ông chỉ
cần bảo sinh viên bóng cho ông một trăm
nghìn mấy tháng rồi em ạ Có 100 sinh
viên các sự thứ phải kiếm gì ấy chứ ông
Ông cứ kiểu sẽ miễn phí cho vui kiểu ông
kéo dạng ông thích cao thượng và Vân gì
Hỏi con tôi tôi tôi thấy thực ra là tôi
cho đi miễn phí nhưng thật ra tôi thương
ấy nó vẫn có gây sự đổ lại gì mà mua cái
vô hình cái đó Tấm nhờ kéo tôi làm kiểm
duyệt cho nhóm utyt ạ
Em à từ nóng miễn phí nho tôi từng nóng
đó rất nhiều và b cũng xây dựng được tên
tuổi và vài người biết đến nhiều người
biết đến hơn được ạ và đến với rộng thế
tôi dạy miễn phí nhiều người biết đến và
nhiều người này chẳng
có thể thời gian nó đem lại cho mình giá
trị nhiều hơn không phải vật chất nhưng
mà một cái giá trị khác mà nó vẫn có
thay đổi ra đồ vật chất nếu phía sau
mình kiểu như nổi tiếng rồi thì cái gì
mình chẳng đổi được
chứ không phải nổi tiếng về sau tôi sẽ
chuyển qua thành quảng cáo nghĩ gì cả
nhận xét là quảng cáo những à Chắc chắn
là nhiều người biết đến thì mình sẽ được
người gì đó được công việc mọi thứ tốt
hơn có tiếng nói hơn và Vân Tôi nghĩ à
rất nhiều người cứ nhìn em cậu dạng mà
phải đi chất tôi nghĩa hướng đến đó là
khi
mình tạo được giá trị cho cộng đồng và
chắc chắn là mình cũng có mình sẽ là một
người đó chị trong cộng đồng luôn à
cho nên à ạ Có nghĩa tôi à quan điểm về
chất khác nhiều người lại
bởi bé hồi bé rồi làm việc nhà nhiều với
nhau mà lớn lên chẳng phải làm gì đến
tay được nhịn
à à
học Mỗi ngày học tầm ba bốn tiếng thế
đâu một ngày chỉ nên họp báo của tướng
Ơi Đừng nhậu nhiều quá
I said ổn anh à
à à
thôi cho bữa hôm nay chị ở nhà tâm chị
chọn xong rồi
chào các bạn nhé
Ừ có gì sẽ bình luận hỏi đáp hoặc ông
Anh muốn tâm sự thì có thể nhắn tin cho
nó sau nhé Chào em nhé
[âm nhạc]